somebody needs to mute their
computer if all if all speakers and mics
are muted there shouldn't be an echo I
just make sure that your that your mics
and speakers are muted as
well and Brad uh the chairman is also a
host correct uh yes I may have a co-host
thank
you let's
begin good
morning today is February
10th
2021 it is 9:05
a.m. as as the chair of the criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuing through executive
order
2020-4 this this public body is
authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
with the potential for executive session
to be held throughout please note that
there's no physical location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate temporaneous during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA 91 day
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
27136 600 or email
HCS
l.n. Us in event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Brad geland the
committee researcher please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member States
their presence please also State whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to no
one I'll take the rooll vice chairman
Welch yeah representative ber yes and
Gary Hopper here with
me representative
Hopper
here representative green here
representative Wallace here
representative testerman here
representative true here representative
Pratt representative maren pres the
clerk is present representative Harriet
G representative
pakus she's unmuted
herself
I am here and
alone representative o'n present Home
Alone representative
or present uh alone in the room
representative
Muse here and alone in the room
representative Newman here and alone in
the room representative
balen
I'm present and I'm at home um and my
family's
here representative
Conley representative kin
Knight here alone in the room but my
family's here as
well representative Bradley here and
alone in the
room I'm sorry chairman abis chair
president representative bden this just
uh for the votes we taken remotely uh
just make sure your video camera is on
time to vote I'll also just state that I
did receive a message from uh
representative G she running about 15
minutes late also representative colney
is anticipated to be present as well he
would be here around
945 I will now rep recognize
representative Marson the leader
Al flag United States of America and to
the
stand
indivisible thank you representative
Marsh thank
you
[Music]
at this time we open the public
hearing
on
ca8 here we'll call Representative Terry
Roy good morning chairman honorable
members of the
committee um it's good to see all your
smiling faces again so
soon I am introducing CR r c excuse me c
C8 it's very it's mouthful um this is an
amendment a proposed amendment to the
New Hampshire
Constitution uh that would prohibit the
legislature of New Hampshire from making
any new restrictions on the right to
keep and bear arms Beyond those which
are already or will be codified in
federal
law the reason I'm introducing this bill
is because I've heard from many
constituents that they're frankly a
little tired of every two years or four
years or whatever it may be that um
power shifts in the state house that
they are concerned about either losing
or having their civil rights infringed
upon based on whatever political winds
are blowing and conquered now we all
have our beliefs on the Second Amendment
and I respect everyone's view on it um
so I'm I'm representing my
constituents
and the reason I left the federal law
portion in there is because I'm also a
realist and I understand the federal
Supremacy so if the federal government
says in its ultimate wisdom that um you
can't have magazines more than 10 rounds
well that's the law of the land until
such time as we can get the Supreme
Court to rule
otherwise um but if it doesn't say that
that would restrict New Hampshire
legislators from making any laws for
example on 10 round magazines if it's
not restricted by the federal law we
can't touch it it would also prohibit in
Hampshire law enforcement from enforcing
any federal laws that ran a foul of our
own Constitution that allows us to keep
them bear arms for example if the
federal government decided that you know
what um we're not going to
allow semi-automatic handguns well the
Hampshire Constitution would not agree
with that that and our law enforcement
could not enforce enforce that that
doesn't mean the federal law enforcement
officers in New Hampshire couldn't
enforce it it just means that our law
enforcement could enforce it and again
the back to the original goal of this is
to keep people from having to worry
about their civil rights every time that
the legislature swings in conquered and
I hope that people who have a different
view of this will
consider the same thing happening with
um other civil rights that they are
concerned
with if every time you know the
Republicans took over we tried to take
away freedom of speech or the Press um
in contravening federal law your
constituents will be equally upset and
have to worry every time so that's the
the basis for me submitting this and I'm
open to
questions representative testerman
thank you thank you very much for taking
my question I was reading the the
legislation and and you're saying that
if the federal
government uh put a 10 pound limit on
magazines we would have to live with
can't can't we enact a a an agreement
that would uh or a law that would
preempt the federal government you know
there is that 10th Amendment that says
you know the states have rights
and I'm a little bit worrisome about
this I agree and if you know if if if I
had my brothers I would say yes but I'm
also a realist I understand how the the
system works and if they did enact such
a law um and the Supreme Court upheld it
um that we would really have no Avenue
we can pass all the laws you know saying
no we're not going to obey the federal
government all we want the only recourse
we have is to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court finds it
constitutional and it applies to the
states um you know it our law isn't
worth the paper it's printed on so my
goal was to try and um keep this
realistic um there are many states out
there and I admire them for doing so
that have made themselves so-called
Second Amendment Sanctuary States and if
we could that'd be great but in the real
world if the United States Supreme Court
says that a federal law is
constitutional and it applies to the
states our Sanctuary law really just
doesn't have any power so I I understand
your concerned representative Testament
and I'm with you but I'm trying to I was
trying to keep this realistic for
now thank
you representative
[Music]
n thank you chairman and thank you
representative Roy I'm glad you brought
up taking away people's rights every two
years and uh based off of the concern of
the political climate and conquered and
how it's not fair to our people and how
we would feel if that would happen to us
every two years and I have to say that I
think this pales in comparison to taking
away the right to being able to choose
on my own person my own body what I can
do with my own health I think that you
still have the right to bear arms and
protect yourself no in this state is
that
correct um if your is your question do
we have the right currently
yes representative N I just ask you I
recognize you for a followup but not not
to State
questions okay I I withdraw thank you
that was good
enough
represent
Muse thank you for taking my question
the the wording in the actual uh in the
actual bill seems to be broader than
what you described it says that any
federal law that infringes upon rights
guaranteed in the New Hampshire
Constitution shall be unenforceable by
New Hampshire law enforcement um any any
federal
law
um are are you suggesting that it ites
it applies more to to more than to this
uh particular Amendment of the
Constitution in other words are you
suggesting any federal law that has
nothing to do with Firearms is that what
you're asking it would appear to be that
broad um well considering where it's
placed um in the in the amendment of The
New Hampshire
Constitution um I would assume a court
would would rightfully infer that that's
what it's talking about
um but representative M I'd be happy for
you to submit an amendment to narrow
that to just gun laws if that's how you
how you
feel thank
you representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question um if the Supreme Court were to
um say that your second amendment that
second Amendment Sanctuary laws are
unconstitutional what effect would that
have on this this amendment to the
Constitution um the effect on it I I I
suppose would be that um it we would
still be limited from passing laws that
that were stricter than the federal law
but
um I think it wouldn't have any effect
on it because that's the way I wrote it
so that federal law still uh was
Supreme so if they say for
example um federal law is that you can't
have anything more than a 10 round
magazine this amendment to our
constitution would prohibit us from
making a law stricter than that saying
you can't have anything more than an
eight round magazine but anything that
we put in the Constitution it said well
no we we're going to disregard that um
would really be a null law it be moved
because the Supreme Court courts ruling
on this
constitution um is what it is and the
only way to overcome that would be to
pass a Constitutional
Amendment to the US
Constitution thank
you representative
B than chairman thank you for uh
representative Roy for taking my
question uh I'm a little
concerned uh about
uh you know there are federal laws right
now that that restrict the uh carrying
of firearms on school property for
example uh to only uh people that have
uh weapon
permits um but our state laws sort of
perid school officials as well as
Municipal uh
uh parties from um restricting any uh uh
Firearms regulations is that not true
and uh uh does that mean that those laws
need to be taken
out well so currently uh you are correct
federal law says that no one can carry a
firearm on school property unless
they're license to carry a firearm we
have legislation that says that U the
state has the um ultimate Authority and
sold jurisdiction to pass firearm laws
so that school boards and and towns Etc
cannot enact their own firearms laws I
do not think that wor this to pass that
that would matter
um because they already
can't do am I answering your question
right in other words this doesn't affect
a law that says no one below us can pass
Firearms laws
already representative bour you
recognized for a followup question thank
you Mr chair um actually you basically
said in your testimony that if the uh
federal government passed a law that
restricted the number of uh uh whether
you could have a automatic uh pistol or
not uh then the state would have to
enforce that law would have to abide by
that law since federal laws already are
more restrictive on uh uh use of fair
the car regulation of firearms on schol
property would not not also mean that
those laws are no longer
valid uh I think I I think I understand
your question but I don't think your
premise is correct currently um there is
no New Hampshire law that cont
intervenes federal law federal law says
that you cannot carry a firearm on
school property unless you're licensed
to do so if a school board decides that
they want to make a law that says you
can't carry a firearm even if you have a
license um that's what's prohibited
right now by New Hampshire law they're
not allowed to pass laws um regarding
firearms on on school property um so the
Hampshire law follows federal law right
now with regards to having to be
licensed to carry a firearm on school
property I'm happy to take another one
from representative board n because he
looks like I'm we're still not getting
to the heart of his question if that's
what he'd
likees we are uh as a practice of the
committee we we're doing our best to rep
limit members of the commit to two
questions per witness due to
time well I'm I'm sorry representative
boord if I didn't get that one email me
and I'd be happy to
respond do you
have a third fall question you wish to
ask um just a point
uh speak we have we're having trouble
hearing you so it is in the discre to
allow a third question but I I actually
couldn't hear your second first or
second question so I'm gonna allow a
third question try to speak
up okay so
federal law already prohibits the the
use the carrying of firearms on school
property unless you have a concealed uh
permit yes however uh local law
enforcement is unable to uh enforce
those laws only federal law enforcement
that not
correct um I I do not believe that is
correct I I believe that um
for example here here's another example
sought off shotguns are illegal under
federal law so are machine guns um I I
believe a law enforcement officer can
can arrest on
that I believe I I believe so
yeah seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the representative for his
testimony thank
you
before we begin calling members of the
public I just want to remind the members
of the public and this will apply to all
hearings today that testimony will be
limited to two minutes per per witness
testified uh with the exception to the
sponsor of the bill or the
representative
introduc Tracy
uh
Han hi thank
you sorry
um it's Han briet um can you hear me yes
we can okay thank you um my name is
Tracy hbet and I'm here on behalf of
myself and the Kent Street coalition
working group on gun violence prevention
which I lead thank you for allowing me
to address the committee today um I will
make this very short um in terms of
public
policy um it's hard to think of a worse
idea than adopting a blanket prohibition
on any type of measure whatsoever that
might improve safety with regard to
Firearms or frankly anything else um I
do understand that some of us want less
government than others but it is a
legitimate interest and function
government to look after the health and
safety of that government's people and
to wholly exempt Firearms which are
um deadly weapons um from the purview of
all future laws um frankly to me is
nonsensical um and I will just add um
that I do understand the frustration
with having to revisit um every two
years um a certain body of Law and and
frankly it's a it's a frustration that
um we share frequently um but that is
the legislative process and nobody
understands that better than than all of
you sitting um as a legislative body uh
and that's simply the nature of of the
lawmaking process
um people do get shot and killed in New
Hampshire um despite what's
frequently um all the testimony that
that we hear and all the words that we
hear about New Hampshire being such a
safe State some of those people do die
in particular the rate of suicide has
risen in a striking manner over the past
decade we do need gun violence
prevention laws because it turns out
that they do save lives so let's debate
the merits of individual proposals
instead of blanket and frankly
unconstitutional measures like this one
um and I don't have any more time so I
can't get into that but thank you for
taking my testimony
thank you for your testimony seeing No
Hands raised I I excuse the
witness calling the next witness uh
Leonard
cor welcome back
Mr did he go oh
can you hear me now yes you can okay uh
yes I'm Leonard K I'm here representing
the New Hampshire Medical Society and
the uh New Hampshire Psychiatric Society
and uh let me add thank you for
listening to my testimony I'm also
representing the American Medical
Association and so many medical
Societies in the country uh that are
interested in gun violence prevention
and I'd be glad to provide the committee
with the 75 or more societies if
anybody's
interested I'm here to express my grave
dissatisfaction with this proposed
amendment and to the many attempts this
year and other years to propose gun
bills that interfere with the US and
state governments attempt to reign in
gun violence in this country rather this
bill and others unfortunately Foster gun
violence in our country and in New
Hampshire to be frank I feel that the
Republican party is mostly lock step in
opposition to sane attempts to curtail
gun violence and to provide for safety
in our
society these efforts fa fly in the face
of two key facts fact number one
numerous Studies have demonstrated that
loose gun laws are associated with more
gun
violence and reasonable gun laws
restricting gun violence are associated
with less gun violence less murders less
suicides by guns and less gun injuries
the second fact is that the US has
approximately 25 times the gun violence
and here I'm referring specifically to
homicide but also um suicide of other
Western democracies relative to
guns let me close this brief testimony
encouraging all representatives to vote
to oppose this amendment and to be on
the side of sanity and safety in our
communities in our state and throughout
our country one further
comment proponents of this Amendment
state that they are concerned regarding
civil rights rights namely their concern
of expansion of interpretations of the
Civil Rights Rel related to the Second
Amendment however the Civil Right of
being alive and safe in our state safe
to remain alive safe to vote safe to
breathe safe from being shot is clearly
more necessary than focusing only on
having more guns everywhere please vote
against this violence prone legislation
let us have a state and Country focused
on love and caring for others thank you
for listening to my
testimony thank you Mr cor doctor excuse
meor seeing No Hands raised the witness
is
[Music]
excused
Dina
Romero can you hear me yes we can thank
you uh good morning uh members of the
committee thank you for hearing my
testimony um I have also uh submitted
written testimony which I hope was
passed out to you um I am against this
amendment because for the following
reasons it unnecessarily pits New
Hampshire state law against federal law
and sets a negative
precedent in vetoing proposed gun
legislation last year Governor n sinunu
said that the New Hampshire uh
Constitution and I quote provides what
many believe believe to be more
expansive legal protections for gun
ownership than the Second Amendment to
the United States
Constitution the right to keep and bear
arms in New Hampshire um cutting off
debate on gun rights by limiting the
ability to pass gun safety laws which
silence the many New Hampshire residents
who believe and want sensible gun laws
the proposed amendment ignores the fact
that gun violence in this country is a
significant Public Health crisis and a
leasing cause of premature death the
proposed amendment is overly restrictive
with the intent of silencing a much
needed conversation on sensible gun
safety laws this is not how democracy
works I wanted to to um uh add the uh
representative pres presenting the bill
talked about people worrying about their
civil rights I quite frankly am more
worried about my physical safety if this
amendment were to be passed and I think
it's time that we prioritize physical
safety I also wanted to mention that in
other rooms this morning there is
discussion about the sanctity of the
pre mro uh we have to limit testimony to
two minutes for
witness you've exceeded your time limit
if you don't mind just concluding your
testimony with a single
sentence I can finish my
sentence I I I just ask that you
conclude your testimony yes yes um so
what I was saying is um there's a lot of
emphasis on the the sanctity of the life
of the
pre-born um and there's less discussion
on the sanctity of those of us who are
already on this Earth and being safe
from gun violence thank you for
listening to my testimony I hope you
will read my written testimony please
vote against this amendment thank Miss
R seeing No Hands raised the witnesses
excused
and for any members in the public that
are in attendance right that wish to
testify please raise your hand now uh it
it will please the chair and allow the
committee to actually uh manage his time
better knowing how many people wish to
testify the
public next witness is Sarah
West hi can you hear me yes we can hi my
name is Sarah West I'm a student at
conquered high school and I'm
representing the New Hampshire High
schoool Democrats we are deeply
concerned about
ccr8 um because it would prohibit the
legislature from enacting Common Sense
gun control laws and doing
so
sorry I cut out can you hear me yes
great um gun control is a public safety
issue and we are terrified about the
prospect of this
amendment as a student I'm also keenly
aware of the fact that there aren't
enough Common Sense gun control laws in
New Hampshire in the first place when
students walk into school one of the
first instinct is to see where the best
place would be to hide in the event of
an active shooter scenario
this is not an abstract fear because we
were trained on gun related lockdown
drills before we could write our own
names I hope that members of this
committee consider the safety and
well-being of students and other Granite
Staters such as myself and oppose
ccr8 thank you very much for your
testimony seeing your hands raised the
witness is
excused
the next witness is DJ
Reynolds
Reynolds you
saw
Mr chairman I don't see that name I
apologize representative Muse if you
could take a
peek keep
it looking for the name I don't see any
telephone uh I don't see any telephones
either
so the next witness would be Alan
Rice
yep Mr rice is UN
unmuted Mr
rice Mr rice may be having technical
difficulties so we'll move on to
another
witness Dr
joannon I've asked him to unmute
himself okay
come
out Allan Allan
rice uh Allan Mr rice just text me said
that he's switching computers all right
will
uh Dr Hannah having difficulties we're
going to try a third witness and
hopefully this works itself
out
Jr
WF good morning chairman abbis can you
hear me yeah perfect we can hear
you not anymore Jo you're muted you
muted
yourself all right I asked him to unmute
again here he is am I back
yes can I can you hear me m chairman
abis yes we we would ask you to speak
up okay good morning good morning
chairman abbis and members of the
criminal justice committee for the
record my name is J.R Hull I'm a former
State Rep and I live in the town of
Dunbarton I am here to testify in favor
of the concept but not the language of
this bill the current language has
significant unintended
consequences I would like to see a bill
that goes for forward that doesn't have
those
consequences um we've heard from
numerous members of the New Hampshire
Firearms Coalition about the need for a
second amendment Sanctuary State and
this is potentially the right vehicle to
do that but the language that has been
drafted and submitted um has some
technical issues so we myself as well as
the New Hampshire Firearms Coalition
stand in support of the concept but not
necessarily the language that is in this
current bill and with that I'll close my
testimony thank you seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
excused Michael
thoron thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael Thornton
Milford New Hampshire speaking as a
member of the
public I am and have been a gun owner
all my life 70
years uh as a minor with supervision
naturally member of the United States
Marine Corps and Air Force I speak in
support of the
concept absolutely
essential the uh Second Amendment is
being attacked so many different ways
however the language of this bill is not
quite
there the concept is absolutely
essential I please
uh suggest that the committee support
and have the bill language amended thank
you very
much thank you Mr Thor for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
Daniel it's
it's
mute there we go sorry that should be
better yes okay thank you Mr chairman uh
members of the committee for the record
I am Daniel itsa uh I am currently
residing in
Manchester uh I am former state
representative and former chairman of
constitutional
review The Proposal you have before you
for a constitutional amendment is
good-hearted it's of good intent however
we must remember that when we are
putting things into the Constitution
particular particularly the Bill of
Rights they should be uh general
concepts broad Concepts and not
particulars uh when you get into
particulars you tend to forget something
so um I've been working on a a better
wording with uh uh former representative
Hull and I think that that we have
something that is uh up to the task but
I want you to remember that what you are
not talking about here is is not
particularly
gun rights or the Firearms rights but it
is the most fundamental of our natural
rights the right of
self-defense and the access to the tools
necessary for that
self-defense and the defense of
others uh it is for this purpose that we
enter into
government and we delegate uh certain of
these powers to the government but the
government cannot always be there
when you're alone at night on the road
uh the government is not going to be
there when you're asleep in your bed the
government is not going to be
there you need to have EV every
individual needs to have
guarantee of their rights to defend
themselves from all attackers uh i' be
happy to take any
questions seeing No Hands raised
witness representative
M uh Mr chair am I recognized yes my
mistake representa so one of the
concerns that we've heard from some of
the other folks testifying is the fact
that this bill uh would also silence
debate on this issue uh and we have
another constitutional issue that we
need to to worry about here uh simply
aside from the the freedom to really
carry firearms I guess as somebody who
has worked on constitutional issues in
the legislature how do you respond to
that well I assume that that because you
didn't state it that the the
compe issue you felt raised as one of uh
right of freedom of speech or debate uh
it certainly doesn't does not silence
debate um the question the question
question at hand would be how you
adequately protect
individuals um who feel themselves at
Danger from such a proposal you have to
remember that what those people are
fearing is Criminal
acts assaults by another person upon
their person or or their loved
ones um no law no constitutional
amendment itself stops such an
individual from aggressing upon another
uh making sure that people don't have
the power to defend themselves does not
ensure that a criminal will not take up
those arms regardless of any law that
might be
enacted representative M you recognized
for a followup question thank you would
you agree that in addition to uh the
potential to prevent crimes that laws uh
of the type that this
uh action might ban might also um
prevent
suicides uh prevent accidents may
contribute to uh fewer situations of
negligence not generally no accidents or
accidents you I mean you you you can't
prevent prevent accidents you have to
remember laws do not prevent crimes laws
punish
crimes criminals commit crimes and they
will do so
regardless what you need to maintain is
the ability to punish those who uh
commit acts of injust injus excuse me
Injustice upon
others uh
represent we're Li we limit the two
questions each member to two questions
for witness I love the accept represent
Bo ex the room actually could hear his
question
so I couldn't
exess see any members have any
additional questions seeing No Hands
raised uh the witness is
excused calling uh next witness is Alan
rice Mr chairman I I apologize for those
earlier technical
difficulties um Mr chairman uh members
of the committee for the record my name
is Allan rice and I am a legal resident
of Bedford New Hampshire and I am here
as the state director for Gun Owners of
America a National Organization
representing over two million Firearms
owners I had sent the committee uh a
letter explaining our concerns with
ca8 um we believe the way this is
written if it were to be enacted as
written um it would actually set New
Hampshire up for more gun control um
maybe not gun bans but certainly gun
taxes because the language says um that
would create a greater burden than that
in federal law federal law currently
taxes handguns at 10% rifle shot
shotguns and ammunition at 11% New
Hampshire could tax them at 9% and 10%
respectively and that would not be a
greater burden um so unless this is
amended um and that language is stricken
uh we would be forced uh to oppose CAC
um right now we're neutral and hoping
that this committee through its wisdom
and Collective knowledge would amend it
um but uh in response to the people who
were claiming Mayhem and blood would
happen um I would say look at
constitutional carry they predicted that
and we have not had any problems over
the past four years so they're just
factually wrong I believe I'm under time
and I'm going to conclude on that
note thank you Mr
rice seeing No Hands raised the witness
is
excused
uh hand was up it's not up
now Mr chairman I do not see him on the
list
anymore
DJ
Reynolds Mr chairman I do not
see she's the one you couldn't
find call again to make so you know
members of the public with a hand raised
at this time the public session on
ca8
and Mr chair the uh the folk the signin
for House Bill uh
ca8 uh 35 people signed in to support
it 166 signed in against it and one
person signed in as
neutral thank you representative
M just remind by the next the next
hearing schedu today is at 10: a.m. so
we will see recess for 8
minutes
we open the public hearing on House Bill
195 represent sign up toce the bill
the hot seat
is do your best to speak up as loud as
possible just to make sure the
microphone inone can hear you we won't
accuse you of yelling would you would
this way no we prefer just to the public
and see you but you may speak as loud as
you you can even yell we won't hold
it desk all right
um hello Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for inviting me back
again um my billh house bill 195 is a
simple bill
um but feel you feel feel welcome to
spend any time you want on it it it is
just one liner it's just one sentence it
clarify something um in RSA 631
sub subsection three something direct L
conduct saying that U display firearm
shall not constitute repace conduct
under this
section that's a gist of the
bill this is something will save a lot
of
lives because as as we know um
throughout the United States defensive
use of a firearm or maybe just speaking
about it saves about 2.5 million lives
every year according to CDC
statistics so this is the gist of the
bill and
if if uh situation can be de escalated
if there's a conflict that may
arise
hopefully
um telling them that you're serious
we'll calm things down and let everybody
go
peacefully and that's what my deal does
it clarify something in this section on
Reckless conduct
um thank you I'll I'll be happy to
answer questions
representative thank you for your
testimony representative Hopper uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for taking my question was there an
instance or instances that um motivated
you to bring this legislation
board um Yes actually in New Hampshire I
believe in Manchester there was an
instance where uh a lady was coming home
from work second
shift and uh she came under some sort of
an attack walk into the house and then
her
husband uh a woken in the middle of the
night ran downstairs trying to to help
her as he should have done and I commend
him for that I believe he he had he
grabbed a pistol to go investigate and
save his wife he probably was not
wearing holster probably was not the P
was probably not being holster he
probably just held it in his hand and he
may have not even be wearing pants at
that point and I believe he got into
some sort of trouble with the LA
because his firearm was not fer properly
he was just holding it trying to save
his wife so this hero should not be
facing any kind of criminal danger any
kind of charges because he was there to
help his lady all of us would have
done thank you thank
you
representative I the chair has a
question
and one one question I have is
so what I guess the term
display I read display to be it's
included in part of the definition of
Rip but it's not in
selfish what would you define our
understand
displaying
um I don't believe it's defined in a
statute but it's a common English word
and when I looked it up in the
dictionary displ saying display were
meant to show or exhibit to make
something visible deliberately with an
in as opposed to be Reckless where you
have no intention you don't know what
you're we can't hear the
witness yes yes yeah uh to display as
defined in the dictionary is to show or
to exhibit to make something
visible that's not care that's not being
careless that's not being
Reckless you know what you're
doing that's your intent you're doing it
carefully you're doing it
deliberately that's what the display to
display
is thank you represent take question
represent G
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question sir um you in given the example
that you gave of someone um Coming um to
protect their wife would you call that a
display I couldn't hear the um first
part I'm sorry you gave an example yes
of a man going to basically to protect
his wife yep that's not a display as
your your description gives so what
would you call that L this ple he had
his farming his hand
but for thank you okay but what was the
intent the intent M he was there to save
his wife okay thank you yeah represent
representative green thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question if a person was on a highway
and there was about to become road rage
if he displayed his firearm this would
uh protect him as well as his family I
believe so and it would actually protect
the attackers too because they may think
otherwise and go elsewhere seeing that
they don't want to continue with the
confrontation it would deescalate the
confrontation I believe and he would
right his family himself would proceed
towards their destination thank Youk
question representative
TZ thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
represent you for taken my question um
this seems like it's going to be that
you
can banish a gun or point a gun at
anybody at at any time and it will not
be recess conduct am I
correct
um so the subsection I think you the
subsection um 631 colum 3 talks about
Reckless conduct and that's not being
Reckless when you deliberately and
carefully something so U that's what dis
plan is uh again it is a verb it is to
show or exhibit something to make it
visible thank
you thank
you representative
wel repr are you aware of the statute
that talks about display of a firearm
and to
off uh thank you yes I am uh this is
part 631 column
4 uh
yes this talks about right this talks
about displaying firearm or other means
of
self-defense uh she not the criminal
under Section 631 col 4
so
criminal right what I'm doing on um
section above it in we clarify
section repres you recognize for a fall
question I was the author of
that a result
of now the display of his firearm result
of I'm getting
convicted I was really upset
over
and was he had the gun in the back of M
when he turned around to walk back into
his
home the woman who had gone through all
kinds of no
trespasses trying to M the and she
was yeah that was that was why I wrot
that I support thank you thank you so
much thank
you representative bur thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for for coming
today if I'm understanding the bill
correctly if I'm walking down Elm Street
in Manchester and somebody jumps out of
a Alleyway and wants to threaten me and
my
wife and I feel instead of shoot
shooting them I just show my gun and
that will scare them away that is
acceptable but if I also want to drive
down the
road nobody's making me nervous or
anything and if I start just pointing my
gun this is what I'm being told is going
to happen is there a question
yes thank you Mr chairman if I just
start pointing my gun there is also a
law against that your law is going to
protect my first scenario not my second
scenario of just driving down the road
poting guns at
people oh so is that correct that the
first part of my yes you know it's going
to protect me
but there is also other laws that will
stop B bad behavior like driving down
the road pointing guns
corre all right thank you sorry for
being confused and I'll just remind the
members uh I'm sure we're going to have
a very healthy discussion the executive
session and uh just I I already had warn
two members
of want to keep want to keep it
equal
representative
news thank you for taking my question um
it it does appear to me that the
situation that you brought up based on
what representative Welch was saying is
actually covered uh in in New Hampshire
law
um
Mike what I'm curious about is is what
you think the impact of a bill like this
would be in a in a road rage
situation where normally two people
might get out of outside of a car um
yell at each other for a couple of
minutes um uh get it out of their system
jump back into the car and drive away uh
if somebody brandishes a gun or a
firearm and the other person uh is also
armed uh but maybe maybe armed so that
they're concealed does doesn't it seem
to you that that something like this
just opens the door for uh a much larger
extent of of potential gun violence on
our
roads
um uh thank you for the question well
this is America and we support and
defend the Second Amendment so you
should assume anybody should assume that
everybody is armed at all times to
display a firearm will just remind
people to warn them off they basically
from trying to escalate the
situation so I I believe this would
actually calm the situation down and all
let the people go peacefully because
it's just a reminder again this is
America this is not some other
place think so I believe that this will
um deescalate the
situation repr
Bradley thank you and thank you for
taking my question um so you mentioned
intent
can a display of a firearm cross into
Reckless
conduct um thank you well so
reckless Reckless uh would it cross
into display has deliberate um intent in
it you're trying to exhibit you're
trying to display it you're trying to
show it I'm
sorry you you're making it visible
Reckless is defined elsewhere um if it's
in the same sub paragraph but in the
dictionary if you look at
Reckless it's got little to do with
being displayed displays to make visible
Reckless is conduct where you don't care
about your actions where you beh
carelessly carelessly sorry um without
caution so reckless right so they are
separate different wordss basically this
point yeah thank you
hope just help guide the members of the
committee I believe in this won't appear
on what the the bill that was printed
out but RSA
631 uh three if you look at Roman one
there is a definition of re so that
makes me
helpful representative
Knight
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question
representative um you mentioned it's uh
it's more of a fear aspect and people
should be allowed to brandish a weapon
for intimidation and safety purposes
that way not necessarily using the
weapon is that
correct uh thank you for the for the
question um well if it's me on the other
side and I don't suppose it'll ever be
but if somebody wants to show me their
firearm I'll be very happy about that I
will appreciate it very much because I'd
rather to be warned than
surprised follow
up represent night you recognize for a
followup question thank you um so what
you're saying these people don't
necessarily need to be trained and
you're okay with an exorbitant amount of
public popul
carrying firearms just to scare each
other um thank you for the question I'm
okay with it being America and people
defending and protecting and using their
Second Amendment right that's why I came
to this
country um that's why I'm here
so have the right to bear arms
and that's it thank you representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
are you aware that in the uh 631 colon 3
Reckless conduct the uh num Roman
numeral 2 says Reckless conduct is a
class B felony if they use a deadly
weapon and all other Reckless conduct is
a
misdemeanor are you aware of that um
thank you for the question yes I see it
right here yes
represent Newman you recognize for a
followup question thank you Mr chair um
do you believe that based on Roman
numeral 2 that this might be an o that
the legislative intent when this bill
when Reckless conduct was passed
intended to make uh the display of a gun
much more serious than any other form of
Reckless
conduct
um thank you it's um we I think we're
thank you for the question I think we're
confused in the two terms Reckless
conduct and displaying exhibiting
something an item are separate things
conduct is actually re as defined in
section one and in the dictionary it's
doing something where you're not
concerned about the consequences of an
action you're doing something without
caution you're doing something care
lessly displaying is an action where you
show an item where you exhibit an item
you have a you know what exactly what
you're doing so they are the
Opposites thank
you
representative
represent around expanding
selfdefense the vehicle um
and uh during the course of that
testimony we heard a number of scenarios
in which one would be then Justified to
use deadly
force um and among the scenarios was
somebody brandishing a weapon uh would
then be perceived as threatening which
would then allow for headden Force so if
people are then were inducing weapons uh
as proposed under this
statute foresee potential problems in
which
um instead of De escalating the
situation as it sounds like you're
hoping it escalates the situation
intool thank you for the question good
question good question um so the vehicle
is a separate separate bill of mine um
so my intent there was that if you're
being kidnapped car jacked if you're
being stopped from leaving which is kind
of a being kidnapped if you cornered
something place you are able to use that
the force to get out of that situation
because in the vehicle you can not leave
all the time if you're surrounded by a
bunch of folks things like that so there
are you Defending Your
Life and you got to do what you got to
do you you may step on the guas and get
out try to get out even if you're trying
you know going to be falling off the
road something like
that
um so that's a separate deal of mind
right
um so being this doesn't talk about the
vehicles it doesn't talk about um being
threatened in a way in that way uh
this
uh let's see yeah so if we're talking
about the vehicle the purpose of the
vehicle is to go someplace point A to
point B so you're trying to get out of
the situation you again trying to
deescalate to do whatever is necessary
to deescalate
it if if you being threatened there's a
yeah well y it
ises recogniz for follow question thank
you represent I interrup
your so would you agree we we also heard
testimony and I hate to keep referring
back to another bill but I do see them
as related um we heard testimony in
support of that bill from member of the
public support of that bill who clearly
articulated
um witnessing someone brandish a weapon
at them as a threatening act that would
then um allow for a threatening or a
deadly force response so I guess um if
uh that would you agree with u that
person who spoke in favor of your other
bill and the concern that they
raised to
this um thank you for the question I
think uh there are two subsections in
the chapter one oh I'm sorry 631 col 3
where I'm I'm I'm trying to make changes
and 631 colum 4 which talks about I
think the scenario you're mentioning
where somebody is being attacked in a
vehicle and they have to figure out what
to do that deals with criminal
threatening that deals with uh let's see
yeah fear of being placed in I'm
sorry uh being placed in fear of iment
bodily injury or other things
so those are two separate subsections
under the
bill so I think what you're getting into
is the criminal
conduct and that drugless conduct is
something different the criminal
criminal
Behavior thank you see seeing No Hands
raised winess excl I want to thank you
for your tone taking our
questions I just I just want to remind
everyone so there is a legal difference
between displaying and Brin
isue I don't mean critique the question
I want say they've been used
interchangeably but there is a slight
difference so this only says displaying
so I
mean I don't mean to be too technical
but I just want to make sure the public
understands that and if they may create
confusion
with I think brandishing would involve
also
displaying a firearm with the intent to
threaten a person by without any just
legal justification for doing so
displaying is ma the int to actually one
you have a justification for doing two
you're not trying to Simply threaten or
intimidate someone without any just cuse
that's a distinguish that's why I when I
as my question what does he understand
display to me displaying is part
of
brid
peny
Dean I just want to remind the members
of the public that their testimony will
be led for two
minutes yes chairman thank you can you
hear me we can hear you okay thank you
um my name is Penny Dean and I'm an
attorney and I won't go through all the
places that I'm I'm admitted in but the
gist of this is is this is really
designed to give people a safe harbor
and to deescalate situations because
there are all sorts of statistics by
Gary kleck who's a very famous Florida
criminologists and others that say the
simple display of a firearm Som
sometimes can diffuse a situation and
although I'm not speaking for the
representative that introduced this bill
I would expect that that's what this is
designed to do and it's also designed to
keep people having a safe harbor simply
displaying a firearm should not be a
criminal charge there are some people
who choose to carry concealed and
sometimes their clothing moves if
they're in a checkout line or whatever
and it's visible and the mere fact of
having a firearm present or what some
people could say displaying it in that
instance should not be a crime and so
this
requires what someone would call
non-criminal behavior in other words
inadvertent Behavior or the deliberate
in some cases it can go both ways of
just showing another a firearm um and
and I would respectfully say this bill
is needed this bill is clarifying other
parts of the section and simply because
some people may not like or care for
firearms should not allow them to bring
cause the police to bring criminal
charges against those who choose to
carry a firearm for
self-defense and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
if I just may ask one question you see
you probably heard me
discussing the term display what do you
understand the term
display displaying is simply to show or
maybe to make someone aware of um
displaying can also simply say to
pointing out or to draw attention to in
this particular context so it isn't the
pointing or threatening it is simply the
showing so in other words it isn't the
say case where I bring out a firearm and
say I say I'm going to shoot you or
point it at your head or do any any type
of other Behavior like this this is
simply showing or drawing attention to
the fact that you are carrying or
possessing a firearm it's not intended
to decriminalize criminal
Behavior thank you for taking my
question representative Hopper uh thank
you Mr chair uh thank you attorney Dean
for taking my question do you know
instances in the state of New Hampshire
where somebody has displayed a firearm
to do deescalate a situation has been uh
successfully prosecuted for doing so um
sadly I do sadly I do and um I think
this is needed to stop that and in many
many cases it destroys a person
financially it destroys them maybe
causes them to lose their job and many
many other things because the mere fact
that someone chooses to carry a firearm
in some particular occupations or
situations May chart um cause people to
say look look what they do so absolutely
this this is going to save a lot of I
think unjustified and unwarranted
prosecutions repr you recognize for a
fall question thank you Mr chair U Can
you email the committee
a couple examples if you have
them I could e um yeah I could email the
committee public examples um of other
people's cases there are some of my
cases that clients wouldn't want any
more attention drawn to but um I'm
trying to think of cases that would be
very clear let me think about that and I
will try to do that what's the timeline
for which when you would want to receive
these
emails
the sooner the
better always um um thank you I think
the one best example that we've heard
about was the ward bird example um
because for example there are times when
someone has a firearm either on their
holster again or carried somewhere else
at the mere shifting of their coat or
something someone will um allege that
this was designed to be a criminal act
that you just were showing me the
firearm to scare me when the person all
they did was simply shift a Cod or do
something else showing that they have a
firearm or inadvertently showing they
have a
firearm representative Welsh attorney
de the difference between display and
brandishing what you agree is if you
remove the gun from the hster that's
brandishing if you leave it in the H and
just open open your coat to show them
your arm that would be a dis is that
correct in general I would agree with
you in in general I would agree with you
um the only situation that I could see
where that might be and I'm just trying
to think of all scenarios but I in
general I absolutely agree with you the
only way I could see a different is
there are a lot of females who carry
firearms and not easily visible places
we might chose to then show them at a
given point but yes
thank
you representative
Muse thinking my question
um I guess my question is is that this
is a method of deescalation appears to
be something uh right out of a wild west
movie so if if you and I are having a
disagreement and we're having a
passionate disagreement and you're on
one side of the table and I'm on the
other side of the table and you
take a gun out and you put it on top of
the
table I I guess my my question is is how
does how does something like that
deescalate the situation es especially
if I have a
gun well first of all and this is one of
the biggest examples that I give people
is that um I attended gun owners in New
Hampshire meetings for probably H 16 18
years no actually probably 20 years and
there are no more passionate dis
arguments and discussions than you will
see with gun owners who tend to be
opinionated never once did anyone use
their firearm to try and intimidate
another person or make a point and I'll
guarantee everyone in the room had one
or two guns on them and so to suggest
that gun owners are going to do that is
is inappropriate and and I think
respectfully incorrect in the sit
situation you're talking about we look
at what's called the totality of the
circumstances so if I were to say
something as well is doing that then
you've got a different situation but
that's not what this is dealing with
this is dealing with the displaying it
not the saying more because in the
situation you're talking about I
Envision the person saying something as
well as taking their firearm out and
putting it in between the two of us I
just don't see that as being protective
of criminal threatening behavior I don't
see this bill is taking away all the
other statutory protections we have for
what I call threatening behavior with
Firearms I think what you're suggesting
is that this now means people can engage
in criminal threatening and I would
respectfully say sir that's not the case
there are plenty other statutes that
deal with criminal threatening behavior
this is simply the showing of a firearm
and it can be in a variety of situations
and I don't I don't think what you're
talking
about I think what you're talking about
a different cat if you
will representative M you recognize for
a followup question thank you in your
opinion would a law like this make
criminal threatening uh more difficult
to
prove I think what it does is clarify
what behavior is Criminal and what
behavior isn't Criminal because what has
happened with this law is you've had
more what I think
improper prosecutions and I'm and I
actually I'm thinking of a case right
now and it's the Stuart Yuri case that I
tried it came out of Milford and what
happened was finally after this person
had gone through I think three years of
trauma who knows how many legal fees
finally when the alleged complainants
got or the complaining Witnesses got on
the sand one admitted well he never
pointed at us and of course instantly
the judge dismisses those charges but
until you can put these people on the
stand and narrow down exactly what the
person's alleged to have done I think
this is going to stop a lot of false
prosecutions prosecutions that should
not have been bought to begin with so I
don't see it as allowing criminal
threatening because I think of the Yuri
case we had two separate jury trials
both times not guilty after just
destroying that man and his family and
then the state still wanted to bring a
third charge against him and fortunately
at the last minute for goodness knows
what reason the they came to their
censes maybe because the trial judge
said you're going to bring more of this
crap in my courtroom and they null pred
it so I don't see this giving what you
might or what some might argue is a get
out of jail free card for bad behavior I
I just respectfully don't see that
happening this is simply the showing of
a firearm because once you add in more
facts like me like the person saying
well you know what I'm going to do next
or something like that they're not
merely displaying they're saying
threatening
words and that's a whole different thing
I think that then we're clearly in
criminal threatening land and the person
can be successfully
prosecuted representative
Newman
thank you um Mr chairman just to clarify
what you just said in the hypothetical
example of a woman that had a gun in her
purse and was in an argument with
someone and opened their gun and took it
out and remained silent would you
consider that Reckless
Behavior in the context if the other
party is threatening them like let's say
they're coming towards them or doing
something that's threatening I would not
consider that I would consider that
displaying a firearm because they're
letting the other party know that they
have a firearm and unfortunately bullies
tend to attack the weak and groups of
people tend to attack the weak and when
they
see that there is a firearm or other
equalizing self-defense tool available
they may choose not to attack them and
so I think that potentially especially
um women who now like me I'm
unfortunately I'm a little bit disabled
in the sense I have a bad hip and a bad
ankle now I'm not the distance Runner I
used to be so I can't run from a threat
I can I can't even walk fast from a
threat the bottom line is that we might
help me and others like me to avoid an
attack and avoid a larger and greater
criminal act simply by showing
displaying the firearm which essentially
hopefully will worn away attack from
those who might have chosen to attack
what they think is a defenseless person
so I think this is going to save a lot
of criminal acts and quite frankly
potentially save people a lot of
injuries and I go back to the Gary kleck
out of Florida criminologist his
research and John lots and many others
that show the mere presence of a firearm
sometime deters much criminal
activity but more oh sorry yes
[Music]
sir seeing no further hands raised I
want to thank witness for comment or
testimony thank you and I would
appreciate passage of the bill
sir uh Tracy burad
Han can you hear me
yes we can hear you okay that took a
couple tries um hello again I'm Tracy H
brette here on behalf of myself and the
Kent Street Coalition working group on
gun violence prevention um I just want
to say simply that uh regarding
definitions and statutes section two of
6313 states that um Reckless conduct is
a classy felony if a deadly weapon um as
defined in RSA
625 11 section five is used and um I
want to focus more on the statutory
definition as opposed to a dictionary
definition so that section says um
deadly weapon means that any firearm
knife or other substance or thing which
in the manner it is used intended to be
used or threatened to be used is known
to be capable of producing death or
serious bodily injury um Firearms
obviously fit that description and so
the law there makes a point of stating
that Rec Reckless use of a deadly weapon
is a felony and so my question there
would be why would you exempt firearms
from that um then you get into the
definition of display and so I think
that that's a really broad term and you
get into a subjective definition of that
and you end up I think at a at a poorly
drafted bill um it's a broad
term inter that can be interpreted a
number of different ways depending on
who's holding the firearm what they're
doing doing with it who's seeing it
where they are what the context is ETC
um and a lot has been said about this so
I don't want to go into too much detail
um but is taking a gun out of its
holster to show it to a friend a display
that should be Reckless conduct um I
don't know where is that person are they
experienced is the gun loaded are you in
a crowded place and I think a lot of the
different people in this room are going
to answer those questions differently
Define reckless differently um and the
example that kept coming back to me
because it came up in this context um in
preparation for the election this fall
um what about someone who's wearing a
firearm Miss h b we have to limit
testimony minutes per witness so you see
time you don't mind just concluding your
testimony yes um so what about someone
um removing a firearm from a holster at
a voting booth uh something a lot of
people have to think about this past
fall so um thank you for the time and I
urge you to vote to itl this this
Bill thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witnesses
excuse I get WR
Dr Dr Leonard Cor
hi can you hear
me can oh good uh so I'm here to uh
provide testimony against HD 195
allowing displaying a
firearm or a weapon now uh as you've
heard in another testimony displaying
can be interpreted in a lot of different
ways display of a firearm if you just
have it in a
holster uh presumably is not uh
displaying it but if you remove it or if
the context of the situation is that you
are um uh displaying it in the means of
threatening somebody else that is a
slippery slope and I would rather not uh
include legislation that would allow
this slippery slope to be a way to
excuse a dangerous or
threatening uh type of action now I'm
here as I said in my previous testimony
on the other Bill representing the New
Hampshire Medical Society the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society the
American Medical Association and many
organizations Medical societies that are
interested in promoting safety rather
than uh danger or
violence this legislation can
potentially lead to dangerous
situations and uh the definition of
brandishing will certainly be uh
questioned if we uh Institute a
legislation allowing
displaying um uh if we leave it the way
it is um we'll be safer so please vote
against this dangerous Bill thank you
for listening to my
testimony thank you thank you Dr
B see seeing No Hands raised the
witnesses is
excused
Dina
Romero
Tina oh Dina I'm sorry don't you did say
Dina yep she is here this
time I can you hear
me yes we can hear you thank you thank
you for taking my testimony um my name
is Dana Romero I live in Hanover New
Hampshire and I respectfully ask you to
vote no on House Bill at
195 my reasons are as follows um number
one we're talking about firearms and we
we refuse to acknowledge that a firearm
is a deadly weapon and it has deadly
consequences the point of the firearm is
to kill or seriously wound another
person please let's remember that when
we talk about
Firearms displaying a firearm is not a
neutral Act of it makes an aggressive
and threatening situation which
statement it makes an aggressive
aggressive and threatening statement
which could escalate a situation and
result in violence uh the person
presenting the bill said this is America
and I would add this is New Hampshire
and not the wild west govern Governor
sus Nunu himself said that New Hampshire
is one of the safest states in in the
United Nation in the nation um and let
me remind you Governor sununu cancelled
his 2021 outdoor inauguration ceremony
as a precaution against protesters
carrying arms I I do want to make one
other comment if I may um representative
of
uh committee chairperson which is about
the process uh would you allow me just a
short two minutes minute to do that
please I was very and have been very
impressed with the process of how you
are taking testimony from people but I
this is the second time an attorney has
been allowed to speak and answer
questions an attorney who is definitely
a pro Pro Second Amendment person and I
would respectfully ask you in defense of
the democratic process that if you are
going to allow a pro Second Amendment
attorney as much airtime as you have
allowed this person I think it would
behoove you to have a a an attorney
present who is a proponent of sensible
gun legislation thank you very
much thank you Mr Romero and thank you
for testimony and I I believe the the
the witness who the attorney testified
her testimony was still limited to two
minutes A lot of the time taken up was
the witness answering questions uh I did
set some grounds for today for time each
member is is permitted to ask
each um witness up to two questions uh
with the third of the discretion of the
chair so a lot of the comments and
testimony provide thereafter was the
witness answering questions asked by the
committee
members so if there is any other members
of the public with a legal background
they're also welcome to speak and I
would encourage uh people with a legal
background to uh come before this
committee your testimony is always
helpful and
insightful is there any questions of of
the
witness
seeing No Hands raised the witness is
[Music]
excused representative debor
aler good morning Mr chairman thank you
very much um am I able to be
heard here just mine thank you very
much thank you committee members House
Bill 195 seeks to add a new qualifier to
chapter
6313 as a refresher that chapter begins
like this a person is guilty of Reckless
conduct if he recklessly engages in
conduct which places or may Place
Another in danger of serious bodily
injury and then follows with this
Reckless conduct is a class B felony if
the person uses a deadly weapon as
defined in RSA
62511 if you dig into 62511 you'll find
that a deadly weapon defines as any
firearm knife or other substance or
thing which in the manner it is used and
this is the important part intended to
be used or threatened to be used is
known to be capable of producing death
or serious bodily injury so I pose this
to you if a person goes walking through
the aisles of Market Basket carrying a
baseball bat around not hitting anything
not necessarily coming near anyone not
saying anything maybe just striding
through carrying it on their shoulder do
you think that behavior will cause alarm
of course it will because a baseball bat
is something unusual to carry around the
supermarket it is not normal it is an
alarming behavior and it should be let's
say you go to a restaurant and the
person at the table next to you pulls
out their 10 and 3/4 inch whing survival
knife with the serrated edge and the gut
hook they put it on the table for
everyone to see why on Earth would they
do that ostensibly the restaurant
provides its own Cutlery that's an
unusual item to bring to a restaurant
it's an alarming situation and it should
be those instances are examples of
coercive control their actions taken to
send a message to the people around them
that the balance of power is in the
favor of the weapon holder
because represent representative I do
have to limit uh testim to two minutes
per witness so if I just would ask that
you conclude your testimony with single
sentence thank you Mr chair those
examples are examples of coercive
control and those create an unequal
power Dynamic it's a form of violence
and as House Bill 195 seeks to codify
coercive control as an act of
intimidation to
silence as a silent threat it breaks
down boundaries it threatens
safety and I ask you to vote in
expedient to legislate on House Bill 195
and not normalize the presence of
firearms in all parts of our lives a
limit testimony to two minutes per
person so I ask in to the public that
you we now include your
testimony representative
Bradley thank you chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
so we've heard a lot about the presence
of a firearm as being a deescalation
method um supposedly because its mere
presence should threaten the other party
into compliance of what the gun holder
wants do you think someone simply
showing a gun is a method of coercing
compliance am I still
unmuted you're muted okay thank you um I
thank you for the question so coercive
control creates an unequal power dynamic
in a relationship it is a form of
violence it's a key factor in domestic
abuse and intimate partner violence um
it's part of the pattern of behavior
that perpetrators use to gain power and
control and coercive control is an act
of intimidation it's a silent threat so
when someone has a firearm they don't
need to brandish it its presence is a
threat alone ask any victim of domestic
violence whose abuser never pointed a
weapon at it but would take it out and
leave it on the kitchen table as a
warning or um ask the victim whose date
ended in sexual assault why they froze
when a weapon came out of the glove
compartment you know just for show or
ask a family member who lost a gun one a
loved one to gun violence and how normal
it feels to be around people who to
their knowledge have no permit no
training and for all anyone knows no
background check in acquiring that gun
because Private Sales don't require them
in New
Hampshire nothing about any of those
instances are improved with the presence
of a
firearm representative
Knight thank you chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
you just spoke to um domestic um abuse
in our state and I was wondering uh
since I'm not sure how familiar you are
with that subject if you could clarify
to us what this bill would do to
domestic uh survivors in this state if
this bill were to
pass um thank you for the question I
will I I will share with you through my
work with survivors of Domestic and
Sexual Violence that um the
normalization of the presence of
firearms in all parts of our Lives is
unacceptable and it creates a
threatening environment everywhere um it
is not a deescalation technique because
we know that the coercive control of
just the presence of a firearm is meant
to send a message to the people around
you that the balance of power is off and
it's in favor of the person who has the
gun on their hip in the back of their
pants on their leg in their jacket
because they've in introduced an item
that's unusual to to their surroundings
to all of our surroundings and they've
created a circumstance where they've
demonstrated they're comfortable with
that threat being out in the community
they're comfortable being the person who
is the threat that is coercive control
and that is the kind of threat that
people who have suffered domestic
violence and intimate partner violence
and sexual assault live with when they
have experienced um that kind of
Violence by perpetrators and then see it
in their community in places where you
shouldn't have to see
it representative green thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
would you believe that many people and
especially some women carry guns that
are
unloaded would I believe that women
women car that some women carry unloaded
guns
yes I believe that the presence of a
firearm loaded or unloaded increases
potential for violence as demonstrated
by the
CDC thank
you the chair would like to ask a
question sure thank you can you explain
your understanding of the difference
between displaying and
brandishing
yes so um displaying um in fact I have
called
up the display the brandishing of a
firearm is the way um is the um the use
of the
firearm as a threat so to you know wave
it around um it's my understanding that
is to take it out throw put it on the
table um to wave it in the air to
display it openly and be threatening
about it to use it in anger or
excitement um that's brandishing display
is showing it so um you know if if you
and I are sitting at a table and you
take your jacket off and you show me you
have a firearm that's a display and I
know automatically that you know the
person in the p in power at that table
is you because you've got the deadliest
weapon at the
table representative
new my question so if I can more or less
paraphrase what what you just said
brandishing uh is the use of a firearm
uh when you're making a direct threat um
and displaying would be used using it uh
as an indirect threat but in either case
it would appear to be that you're using
it make a threat um would you agree with
that um so I think um I I appreciate the
question but I really want to um I want
to dial back to what we actually have in
statute and in chapter 625 semicolon 11
part five when we're using the
definition of deadly weapon it means a
firearm knife or other substance or
thing which in the manner it is used
intended to be used or threatened to be
used is known to be capable of producing
death or serious bodily injury so in our
statute we have already codified that we
know that a firearm can is capable of
producing death or serious bodily injury
and what HB 195 wants to do is take that
out and and you and add it as a
qualifier
so it doesn't make the guns any less
deadly it just makes the person using it
that much more
dangerous thank
you representative uh the chair would
have a question and I just want to thank
you in advance for taking my question
for taking my
question and this correct me if I'm
understanding your testimony correctly
is there are you saying that there's not
any way to disting to display a firearm
without actually threatening someone at
the same
time um my testimony is the presence of
a fire
Firearms as a deadly weapon which we
have codified in our
statute we know to be it to be capable
of producing death or bodily injury and
when a firearm is present it creates a
situation of coercive control and as has
been um demonstrated in previous
testimony and in questions from um
members of the
committee the uh intent is to actually
create coercive control um whether that
coercive control um is intended to be
de-escalating or escalating there's
actually no way to know what the person
who is ex who is creating the coercive
control you don't know what their intent
is but we do know because we have
defined deadly weapon in statute as
something known to be capable of
producing death or serious bodily
injury so when you introduce that
coercive control into it into the
situation there's no way for anybody
else to know the
intent you have for displaying or
brandishing because you have the most
deadly most lethal thing in the
situation
thank you thank you very much for taking
my
question you you seem to
be lobbying or
for a we have a law which allows open
carry so you're you really seem to to
avoid all this coercive as we would be
better
off dis always displaying our gun in the
open no carrying it under the under your
code or whatever so are are you saying
that that's what you think is the better
option um may I ask who's asking the
question I can't I can't
tell sorry
representative has thank you very much
representative testerman um my testimony
here is against the in the adoption of
House Bill
195 which which seeks to create an
exception for the display of
firearms in house in RSA
6313 so that's my testimony here today
is that we should not be amending
6313 to create an exception for
firearms thank you representative Knight
thank you question of the chair I feel
like
[Music]
um raising a point yes can I please
point of order is
recognized I think it's inappropriate
for either side whether we like what
we're hearing or not to insinuate
another member is a lobbyist when
they're respectful member of our house
and I found that a little disrespectful
with all due respect thank
you she's uh representative m i I
appreciate the point of order I will
just just to address I don't I feel the
term when it was used by the
representative tesman wasn't intended to
imply lobbyist I think he mented as a
form of AD advocacy if you swap the word
advocacy or advocating with word
lobbying um I can understand your
confusion though but I didn't perceive
it that way I don't believe represent
Tes meant it that way in um just to
State for the public the representative
testifying is not aot clarify thank you
for that I appreciate
it seeing no members with they with the
hands raised I want to thank the
representative for tesy thank
you Jack Jackie
wolf yes I am a member of the emergency
Corps of New Hampshire I am a a
registered nurse in Massachusetts but
now living in New Hampshire are you able
to hear
me yes we can hear you okay so uh
just I would like to uh say that in New
Hampshire one second I'm
sorry uh the
CDC statistics tell us that in New
Hampshire
between
207 and
209 uh and and 216 to 218 there's been a
110% increase in deaths by gun ages 10
through
24 in New Hampshire we are the state
that is the highest increase in deaths
by gun in the entire country according
to the CDC
statistics and that's my simple
statement uh I think I have great
concern as a nurse who'd worked with
brain
injured uh young adults in the past and
often those injuries were by death war
by gun and ultimately often uh uh
resulted in death of that young
population that's that's all I have to
say thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
[Music]
excuse Mike
Thon
thank you Mr chair Representatives I am
Mike Thornton a Milford resident since
1993 I come to you as an
individual uh I am in favor of
195 the reason being is absent that I
would have been forced to shoot a
person I was in the low break it State
Forest a young man was in contravention
of the rules of the forest was
discharging a lever action
firearm I happened to be the person he
was shooting at he said he thought he
was shooting at a dog he was shooting at
the top of my
pack I flanked him by the way I'm a
marine enlisted Marine Vietnam Air Force
officer space shuttle
program I came around his back backside
and I ordered
him with nothing in my hands to drop his
firearm he levered the action closed and
pointed it at me I then Drew my 45
showed it to him at a 90 degree angle
away from him and again ordered him drop
your
weapon that worked I took his firearm to
the Lal drit State uh to the Low drit
Police
Station turned it in told the sergeant
at the desk what had
happened in a case that I was not
allowed to show my firearm until in
extremist I would have had to draw and
shoot
immediately that is
unacceptable somewhere
between lies the answer I am not asking
to draw my weapon and and
to uh settle an
argument I am asking to be able to use a
tool
to Mr thoron we do have to limit
testimony to two minutes per witness
retirements expired so I just ask ask
that you conclude your testimony with
one additional
sentence that's all I'm saying it's a
tool for
deescalation U I'm also saying
that uh percentages can be manipulated
I'd like to hear the absolute numbers on
that 110% increase thank you for so
much thank you Mr Thorton for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
there is a phone number person that the
hands raised we don't have a name well
we just ask that you identifiy your full
name the record where you're from and
whether you are testifying in support or
an opposition the house to the house
bill
195 good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Jay
simkin uh I live at 20 Tabit Drive in
nashille New Hampshire a couple
disclosures I'm a federally licensed
Firearms dealer I'm also an
international economic
consultant
um
generally and I've only listened to part
of the
testimony it seems that there's a
concern that the display of a firearm
somehow conveys threat
I understand
that the point I wish to address is this
uh a prior witness referred to some CDC
statistics the CDC is a huge
organization and
produces many many hundreds of series of
Statistics but the
gravamin of the witnesses testimony is
that new h sure somehow is becoming a
less safe
place I will site to a very specific
source and it's a well-known Source it's
a series published by the FBI called
crime in the United States they've
published it in its present form since
about
1961 data published in table four Under
The Heading of incidents of violent
crime show that in
2019 New Hampshire went from the third
safest state in the Union to the second
safest state in the Union again this is
incidents of violent crime per 100,000
residents that metric means that the
incident is adjusted for population
differences between the various States
from at least
2001 through 2018
excuse me we do have to limit testimony
to 2 minutes per witness if you don't
mind just concluding your testimony with
an additional
sentence hello oh
yes um we have to limit testimony 2
minutes per
so if you don't mind your time is
expired you just you don't mind just
concluding your testimony with one
additional
sment um I'm sorry I could not hear that
which you just said
sir we have to limit testimony to
members of the public to two minutes per
witness your time is expired so the
chair is just asking that to let inform
you of your time is expired but also
allow you one additional sentence to
just conclude your
testimony basic
if I have one sentence it is this New
Hampshire is now the second safest state
in the Union with relatively few firearm
laws and any suggestion to the contrary
defies the data as published by the FBI
which data are
authoritative thank you Mr chairman I'll
be happy to answer any
questions thank thank you for your
testimony morning so seeing no seeing No
Hands raised the witness is
excused Dr Joe
Hannon I am here can you hear
me
hello yes great okay good to be here
thank you very much members of the
committee for listening to my testimony
this morning my name is Dr Joe Hannon
I'm the vice president for gun owners of
New
Hampshire and uh we are in a strong
support of uh voting this bill ought to
pass uh we've heard that uh about the W
bird case in n in
20110 uh in response to that case the
criminal threatening statute was amended
to add paragraph four which states and
we've heard a person who responds to a
threat which would be considered by a
reasonable reasonable person as likely
to cause serious bodily injury or death
to the person or to another by
displaying a fire or other means of
self-defense with the intent to warn
away the person making the threat shall
not have committed a criminal act under
this section The Reckless conduct
conduct statute was also subsequently
amended so that it was no longer subject
to the sentencing provisions of RSA
6512 section
2G uh subsequently Ward bird sentence
was commuted in 2011 and go New
Hampshire go Hampshire is of the mind
that the proposed amendment to The
Reckless conduct statute comports with
the sentiment behind the amendment to
the criminal threatening statute if a
person threatens another with a firearm
they will be charged under the criminal
threatening statute but if they display
a firearm with no threat it ought not to
be a
crime um this bill will make people
safer it's better to warn than to act uh
this gives people the option displaying
Firearms are used much more often to
prevent a violent attack than they are
used to shoot and self-defense and
lastly I'd like to just say you know
we've heard about Drive uh different
what is reckless and what is brandishing
and other things we know that driving is
legal reckless driving is not driving on
the shoulder is reckless but swerving
onto the shoulder to avoid an accident
is not Reckless and would be considered
prudent by most we should at least be
consistent with our laws and make sure
that our criminal threatening statutes
are in line with our Reckless conduct
statutes and don't differ in in any way
from any of the other parts of our law
so I I urge you to pass this and I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
very
much see no hands raise I want to thank
thank you for your testimony thank
you
number I believe
so Mr
[Music]
chairman I did not lower their
hand
ch
hello members of the committee can you
hear
me
yes MERS of the criminal justice
committee can't hear
you
while you're having technical
difficulties we're going to move on to
another witness we'll call you directly
after at this time we'll
call Xander rice
Hawkins hi can you hear me yes we can
hear you thank you my name is Andrew
rice Hawkins I'm the director of
gunsense New Hampshire a project of
Granite State progress we oppose House
Bill 195 this bill would exempt
displaying a firearm from The Reckless
conduct law that law currently States a
person's guilty of Reckless conduct if
they recklessly engage in conduct which
places or may Place Another in danger of
serious bodily injury it's very
important to note that that is about
danger of serious bodily injury Reckless
conduct is a class B felony if a person
uses a deadly weapon or misdemeanor for
all other Reckless conduct there's also
provision that if the victim and
defendant were intimate Partners or
family or household members a conviction
is listed as a reckless conduct domestic
violence house will 195 in his attempt
to exempt displaying a firearm from The
Reckless conduct law this dangerous move
gives a free pass to anyone who wishes
to recklessly display Firearms to harass
intimidate coerce control or threaten
others from domestic abusers to Armed
extremists RSA
6274 uh colon 2 - A already allows a
person who responds to a threat which
would be considered by a reasonable
person as likely to cause serious bodily
injury or death to the person or another
to display a firearm with the intent to
warn away the person making the threat
without having committed a criminal act
the bill before you is unnecessary and
dangerous it erodes basic personal
Liberties against armed intimidation
harassment and could allow domestic
abusers more power we urge you to vote
it and expedient to legislate thank you
than
you thank you thank you Miss
Hawkins seeing No Hands raised I I want
to thank the witness for our testimony
witness is
excused Jr hold we we are calling you
again we hope you resolve your technical
difficulties
Mr chairman he just messaged me saying
that he uh is on a telephone but I have
not seen his
number I could try to resolve this if
you want to call somebody else Mr
chairman we'll call uh Alan
Rice
good morning um can you hear me sir yes
yes we can hear you thank you again for
the record my name is Alan Rice a
resident of Bedford New Hampshire and I
represent Gun Owners of America a
National Organization I have submitted
written testimony to the committee and I
just want to comment on some of the
things that those who oppose this bill
have stated um I think they have it
exactly opposite um a victim of domestic
violence
a victim of Street violence a
shopkeeper um yes the presence of a
firearm does reverse the balance of
power and enables a victim to survive
this bill is about defensive display
defensive display is not the same as
brandishing brandish is to wave or
flourish something especially a weapon
as a threat in anger or
excitement display is to show a
prominent exhibition of something
whether the firearm is displayed in a
holster or someone's holding it in a low
ready position prepared to defend
themselves either way that turns the
tables on the attacker and the victim
probably won't be a
victim defensive display should be
specifically lawful in New Hampshire and
this bill would do that and I would urge
the committee to vote house bill
195 ought to pass without Amendment or
change and I'm happy to entertain
questions thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank you Mr rice for your testimony the
witness is
excused we have a phone number uh just
please identify yourself for the record
by stting your full name uh where you're
test where you're from and whether
you're testifying in support or
opposition the house bill
195 yes good morning this is J.R Hull um
of the town of Dunbarton former State
Rep good morning members of the
committee can you hear
me hear you yes okay I am testifying on
my on behalf of myself personally as
well as the New Hampshire Firearms
Coalition in support of the bill before
you this bill will in fact allow gun
owners not to be recklessly charged
um with criminal activity when there has
been no crime I think there's a lot of
paranoia and fear Mong green going on
and I want people to understand that the
mere display of a firearm is not a
criminal
activity the um escalation of a of a
heated argument um maybe uh actions on
behalf physical actions on behalf of one
of the parties in it in an altercation
is different and that's already covered
under criminal threatening statute
this is something where someone's jacket
um is picked up when they bend over at
the store or something and there you
could have someone charged needlessly um
with a crime where there has been no
crime so I would ask that you would
support this bill um as filed with no
amendments or changes thank you so
much representative Bert thank you Mr
chairman and thank you you a former
representative for your
testimony so we've heard testimony and I
just want to clarify it one more time
because I think you alluded to it if a
woman or a
man regardless of gender wants to abuse
their significant other and they pull a
gun out just set it on the kitchen table
you know there's laws against that
correct I if someone is threatened
another there is an entire section of
statutes that covers criminal
threatening it is it is irregardless of
whether there's a firearm involved or
not it could be another another tool
like a knife or um it could it could
just be based on sheer size um women in
particular don't have the same physical
stature that men do so they're at a tech
a technical and a tactical disadvantage
if there is somebody who is much larger
in statute who's making verbal
threatening or um comments and this
levels the playing field so I think I I
hope I've answered your question but it
has nothing to do with the firearm
criminal threatening is an act by itself
regardless of whether there's a firearm
there thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for
testimony seeing no members of the
public present with their hands
raised at this time at this time we will
close the we will adjourn the Public
heing House Bill
195 moving forward uh at this time at
criminal justice Public Safety Committee
we are going to open the public hearing
on House Bill
307 Mr chair we also have some uh uh we
have signin from the previous Bill HB
195 uh 42 people signed in in uh in
support of the bill 156 people signed in
in opposition uh and no people signed in
as
neutral thank you
representative
representative Norm
silver yes Mr chairman uh thank you very
much uh Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Norman silver state
representative from belnap 2 which are
the towns of Guilford and
Meredith uh Bill
307 deals with a rewrite of RSA 159
colon 26 which we thought was our
preemption or Firearms preemption
statute this was passed several years
ago in an effort to make uniform across
the state that the state alone was the
source of any Firearms
regulation what has happened since its
passage it's only 11 lines long and it
has really very little enforcement
mechanism what's happened since the
passage of 159 col 26 is that various
insundry uh government entities uh and
even individuals operating uh Government
properties under leases and things of
that sort uh have undertaken to adopt
rules regulations ordinances uh that
seek to regulate Firearms
notwithstanding
15926 so the point of the the hb3 307 is
the recitation that a recognition that
New Hampshire is not a home rule state
we don't let the individual
municipalities and and lower government
agencies and uh entities just decide
what they want to do on their own we
haven't granted them that power the
power comes from the general court the
general court has previously said it
wants to preempt all firearms regulation
but because of the weaknesses in
15926 uh I have brought forth uh Bill
307 which makes it crystal clear in a
lot more lines unfortunately than 11
lines of the original statute and a lot
more lines that all firearms regulation
must be done at the state level not the
local level and it provides for an
enforcement mechanism and it provides
for the ability of anyone who uh is
agreed by passage of some of these uh
basically unlawful uh enactment by local
agencies to get them rescinded and if
not uh you know relatively promptly
rescinded there are some Financial
penalties involved so that's the whole
purpose of this it's really to make it
crystal clear that when one when we
adopted
15926 effective in 2011 we really really
really meant it so that's the whole
purpose of
hp37 I'll be happy to take any
questions representative cman thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
representative for taking my question
can you give us a couple of examples
that exist right now of where this is uh
been the power has been usurped by a
local state or
schools well of course there's been a
wide publicity of the adoption of
gun-free zones by local schools school
boards within the state uh I'd be happy
to compile a a schedule of all the
reported instances of basically
violation of 15926 by local entities I
don't have the whole list in front of me
now but I think we we've seen a lot on
online we've seen public publicity of
school board members saying well I'm
going to introduce a uh a resolution
that we're going to adopt a gun-free
zone in XYZ town or
city
I'll be happy to provide the committee
with a list uh after the testimony is
concluded represent test you recognize
for a followup uh what I was thinking of
was the rules
are in particularly at UNH you and I are
familiar with UNH
unfortunately but what about those
rules yes I mean if if it's basically
what what one what house bill 307 does
not affect any privately owned property
but if it's government own government
owned property if it's public
property then the public has the right
to its second amendment rights and its
rights under the New Hampshire
Constitution and under constitutional
carry which the legislature has passed
previously and the the the people who
are in control of whether it's UNH or
Plymouth state or keing or any of these
public
institutions should not have the right
they do not have the right currently but
they just ignore the prohibition of
15926 now if you get into a private
school like Dartmouth they can do
whatever they they can prohibit whatever
they want to it's private property but
it's not government property it's
private property and anybody that wants
if you go to a store and they want to
put up this is a this is a gunfree Zone
they're welcome to do that but not a a
government-owned publicly owned
property thank
you representative
pus thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question is are you saying that this law
will fine the cities and towns if they
don't B it yes and and that fine will
come from the state
No it should come from the people who
pass the laws that they know are against
the statutes we've already
passed follow
up repres pus you're recognized for a
followup and are you saying I I'm sorry
but I don't understand what you mean uh
are you going to find the school board
members or council
members personally if they pass a a
local rule ordinance uh or or regulation
that is contrary to the statute yes they
should be subject to
fines thank you
representative Hopper uh thank you Mr
chair uh thank you representative for
taking my question do you know of
anybody in the state of New Hampshire
that
violated uh one of those local
ordinances that have been successfully
prosecuted for before the
violation no I do
not
question I was still writing the answer
from
prev representative poer can you just uh
the M CL asked if you could repeat the
question oh the question was did the
representative know of any instances in
New Hampshire where somebody has
successfully been prosecuted for for
violating a local ordinance on on
Firearms which is expressly against the
state statute that says they don't have
right to pass those uh
ordinances
you want me to repeat my answer my
answer is no I do not know of any
specific instance but the existence of
those regulations or ordinances passed
contrary to
15926 or has a chilling effect on
constitutional
rights representative uh
Muse thank you for taking my question
representative Silber as I understand
your bill uh it would appear to give any
citizen of the state the right to bring
uh a civil action against a community in
violation of this provision uh so if I'm
understanding it correctly um if Hanover
was to pass a law that uh violated this
statute uh somebody in Salem could bring
suit against them is that correct
yes
representative
Newman this is sort of a follow on to uh
representative Muse's question if in
fact these new
penalties um that are put into effect
for the individuals on boards like
School boards and Boards of Alderman and
whatnot do you have a concern that that
would uh limit the number of people that
would want to hold those
positions it may have a limit on people
who might want to serve on those boards
to enact law local ordinances and rules
and regulations contrary to the state
law representative Newman do you have a
followup question yes yes I do um the
other question I would have in the case
that ref representative Muse brought up
where an
individual um sued successfully a member
of a school board or or whatever
board where would the funds go if they
get uh money
damages I would assume that they would
go into the general fund of the
state thank you
uh Mr chairman point of order
please representative B you were
recognized for a point of order thank
you Mr chairman um you know I'm sure it
wasn't intentional but when a
representative on the committee that is
at home zoom in uh ask a question should
they be visible I know they have to be
during voting I just didn't know if they
should be so the public can see you know
the representative asking the question
thank you representative point of order
my understanding of the rule is that the
video for the representatives dis home
must only be turned on when you're are
voting during the executive session
however I would encourage the
members participate when they ask a
question you turn their video on I just
think it's it's for a better better
hearing but it's not required thank you
Mr
chairman
representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
question the
meis enion in this
bill one way to address this I'm having
trouble
hearing representative ra my voice my
apology would it not better to address
this potential um
overreach we want to use that term by
allowing the voters of that Community to
um respond by removing people who are
doing things from the school board or
Town Council that they do not agree with
rather than opening those people up the
um
lawsuits that would be the case if we
were a home rule state but we're not a
home rule state and this is these
actions are violative of State law
adopted by the general court in a
non-home rule state yes the voters
should turn the people out of office
that would be the normal normal result
in a home rule state but this is not a
home rule
state
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for taking my
question I'm looking at
section8 it
said that public funds and will not be
used to purchase uh insurance or defend
any action or damages an attorney field
this sort of uh a violation of uh the
the rights of uh those boards to
uh help their membership
members indemnification of members of
boards is appropriate when the members
are accused of something but not but is
often not provided when they are found
to have violated state law or a
fiduciary duty so in in the case where
they violate state law or a fiduciary
duty indemnification whether it's in the
form of insurance or uh any kind of
indemnification provision that they have
in their own local ordinances would not
be appropriate they're violating state
law this is an intentional act it's not
a this is not something that's done
simply by negligence this is an overt
act that they've taken so that if it's
an intentional act insurance normally
doesn't even protect even liability
insurance doesn't protect against
intentional
acts thank
you do you have a followup question yes
I do thank you thank
you um so if this organization school
board for example uh were to pass a a
ordinance against
Firearms uh that would be as a
collective not as a individuals would
you be uh this go get uh collect funds
from each individual board member that
voted for the ordinance or would it come
from each uh member of the board
regardless only those who voted in favor
of contrary to Public
Law contrary to state
law if if there's a member of a board
who disagrees with the vote and states
on the record their disagreement with
the vote they would not they should not
be subject to being
fined
representative
M representative M you're
muted thank you uh thank you for taking
my question representative Silber do you
believe that the same standard uh that
you're that you're calling for for local
city officials should apply to
uh State officials at the state level uh
if they violate uh federal laws and
federal
requirements I don't know the answer to
that question representative uh that's
you know I've never even I never
examined that issue in the context of
violating federal
laws don't know the
answer
seeing no further questions I would like
to thank the representative for his
testimony thank you for your
attention at this time the the chair
will recognize representative Jess
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair this is a
representative Jess Edwards representing
uh Auburn Chester and Sandown uh I just
want wanted to give a specific example
that uh that stuck out in our community
um shortly after passing the the
original Law we had the timberlan school
district in violation of the law pass
their own anti-un measures and um when I
talked to the some community members
that knew that District well and knew
the superintendent well um the the
feedback I got and admittedly this is
second at hand but um the the the the
common sense uh approach to to thinking
about his action was that um uh he was
uh beyond having anything enforced on
him and Timberlane already hires
attorneys and so he had the taxpayers of
his district ready to defend uh his
illegal act uh contrary to state law so
I I am in favor of 307 if not every word
of it certainly the concept we we have
intentional scoff laws out there um and
it's violating our citizens rights so I
think we need to do something about it I
I'll take questions if there are
any representative green thank you Mr
chairman uh to representative silver
my question is if you had a teacher that
was uh trained and licensed to carry a
firearm the teacher would be able to
carry this in the
school if that's for representative
Silber I I I think I have the floor but
you can excuse me Mr
chair representative to direct a
question to either one well
representative Edwards is the witness
testifying
so please representative
Edwards
did you repeat your question I'm sorry
representative green I was confused who
was taking the question was trained and
licensed to carry a firearm this would
not restrict them from carrying that
firearm I I don't believe so I think
that's consistent with the law that the
legislature passed and the governor
signed thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the represent for his
testimony TR Tracy
per Tracy foret Han excuse
me can you hear me now excuse me can you
hear me now
hello okay Tracy hreat I'm here on
behalf of myself and the Kent Street
Coalition working group on gun violence
prevention I'm here to testify against
hp37 because it seeks not only to expand
our state's existing preemption law but
it specifically targets schools and it
severely punishes individual public
servants for even attempting to save
lives in their own communities it's not
a bill merely to PR OTE proun policies
but it's intended to wipe out any gun
safety attempts and to do that with a
Vengeance it would mandate that no
public K through2 school or the New
Hampshire University system as well as
other public entities could take any
measure to prohibit parents teachers
staff visitors or students from carrying
or storing guns and it would do this to
despite mountains of evidence showing
that children's curiosity for example
when they find guns accidents that occur
at schools with guns substantial
increased expenses by universities that
must be born by these universities when
they're forced to allow guns on campuses
um allowing High suicide rates among New
Hampshire's young people and
more New Hampshire education officials
and others um they need the ability to
determine how to deal with these
problems what they most certainly don't
need is to have the legislature tie
their hands behind their backs and
threaten them with $100,000 in punitive
damages for starters and then forbid
them to pay these punishments out of
their insurance policies all for the
crime of trying to care for their
communities um it seems like this whole
morning has been about legislation
designed to elevate the gun interest
above any other interests and this is
just backwards and
wrongheaded those who believe in the
sanctity of the gun do have their rights
but other interests including human
interests are just as important I urge
the committee to please remember that
and to vote to itl this punitive
h307
thank
you thank you for your
testimony seeing no hands rais up the
chair will excuse the
witness representative
Horgan you're recognized by the chair
thank you very much Mr chair um I didn't
know my hearing in judiciary would get
over in time for me to speak to this and
yours is running a little long um I'm
represent Timothy Horan I represent the
towns of Durham and Madbury Durham is
very significantly the home of
University of New Hampshire and um they
may or may not have someone speaking I
don't see who's sitting in you can't see
who's sitting in the virtual Gallery but
I know they're extremely not interested
in allowing just anybody to have carried
guns on campus I know that annoyed I
know at least one member of this Comm
committee uh sort of complained about
this U we had the uh session days at UNH
especially since they do allow some
people to carry guns for example uh we
had a police presence at our sessions
and even some members of the National
Guard so they uh they want very much be
able to do the same thing Dartmouth or
any uh private institution so-called
private institution does which is be
able to set their own rules for guns um
they mostly ban gun in the campus
residence the classroom buildings and
they and all sorts of other things that
are legal so the mere fact that guns are
not illegal doesn't mean that uh UNH
like any other any other institution
might not want them to be restricted on
their premises so that's uh that's their
theory is is having fewer guns on campus
is better better for security not
everybody necessarily agrees with that
but that's a that's their decision they
should be free to make it just like Dart
and
actually amount of money the UNH gets
from the taxpayers percentages uh it's
about 10% from from State funding then
there's some federal funding that's
actually not that much different than
what the private institutions doing
consider all the grants and the other
things too also I always finds ironic
with all those bills we're always very
about gun owners inadvertently breaking
the law and so I'm kind of surprised I'm
not really into guns I do own a car
which is also like a very expensive very
dangerous object which and I'm really
kind of baffled that somebody who's you
know somebody who's into guns is somehow
not aware you can't expect them to
beware the fact that guns aren't allowed
everywhere or that laws are different in
different places I've never quite
understood that I know I just know as as
a motorist as somebody who likes to
drive I know my car is not allowed just
anywhere I can't just drive it just
anywhere I
want representative Morgan we do have to
limit testimony to two minutes per
Witness if you don't mind concluding
your testimony with a single
sentence think he's
done your
testimony uh oh I'm sorry yes I I was I
figur I pretty much finished I mean
there's more I could say but apparently
I've I've used up two minutes I didn't
hear the announcement at the beginning I
came in before re while R Silber was
speaking so that's I there's a lot of
other reasons um think a lot of Reason
Wise It's a bad Bill and actually
educational institutions um they
probably represent representan I I'll
allow you one sentence to conclude your
testimony um well that that's it I think
and I I think especially educational
institutions uh should be Exempted from
this bill and the whole bill should be
it but even if you do pass it you should
leave out the educational institutions
in particular so um thanks thanks
bye see no represent board
name you have a
question thank you chair thank you m
representative my question um federal
law already uh for H hibits firearms on
public school
property um state law 159 col in 26 uh
prohibits uh school boards and munities
from
uh uh opposing
regulation about Firearms uh this bill
of
307 basically States penalties for
violation of 159 9
26 um is it not true that school boards
could actually ask uh federal law
enforcement to enforce uh Firearms uh on
school
property um basically basically yes but
it's um Most states also have a state
law that parallels um parallels that um
I'm not necessarily the expert on it but
I I have supported bills about guns on
campus guns on on school property so it
is a violation of federal law but it
would be better if we had a state law
and of course this goes beyond the
status quo and actually like uh forbids
any type of anti- firearms rules on
school property and that as I said
before that's inconsistent with the fact
that schools appropriately ban all sorts
of things that are allowable outside
premises of the school and there I think
there's a good argument made that people
should not be carrying firearms um on on
on on on the campus of any type of
educational institution except for
except for certain purposes so that's
um yeah that's about the best answer I
got there you recognize for a followup
question chairman so I know there is
another
bill on that's in the legislature right
now to uh allow
uh state law enforcement
federal law in this case then there will
be a
conflict state law enforcement and
federal law and uh would the law
enforcement agent or law enforcement
officer um have to choose which laws to
enforce um I'm it's probably good point
I can't really answer that any detail I
do I can say that which as I repeat
which I I guess I already point I
already made but maybe I'll make it a
second time as quickly as can that it's
states that have guns in school that
allow State scho
districts most in Most
states the wayt this will suspended has
been a point of order raise
representative Wallace you're recognized
for a point of order thank you Mr
chairman presently we're discussing
House Bill 307 not the other bill so I'd
like to get back on topic in in front of
us uh thank you representa Wallace for
your point of order
I I agree that we are it's currently the
the public hearing that's open right now
is for house 307 so we try to keep the
testony narrow to that we do have a lot
of members at the public waiting to
testify May
question okay um I mean I I think I
already answered repent both repent
board's questions as best of my ability
they're both very good questions you the
the second one um second one that's the
subject of of other bills as well so
would be better um I mean the school
there is it would be easier for law
enforcement to enforce you know problems
with firearms on any type of campuses um
if we had a state law that paralleled
the federal law which Most states do so
and
there's that's a subject that's probably
a topic for another day not necessarily
I'm not necessarily the best person to
address the issue but that's that's my
understanding of itrees with this that
statement thank you represent organ oh
thank you thank you Mr chair so seeing
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
the representative again for his
testimony
you
thank
representative assistant chair
ofation Tom to
ptos uh yes thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee um I just want
to say a few words about this bill um
and why I co-sponsored it I have a
constituent um who works for the State
uh he drives in a vehicle all over but
he's also a police officer in our town
and has training he has applied several
times to get an exception so that he can
carry a firearm in the car in his
vehicle
and the department um hasn't even
followed its own rules now when police
officers were um at risk around the
country um he was very very concerned so
I am hoping that you will uh look at
this bill carefully and understand that
it's not just about schools as people
are saying it's about public uh
government property and
public uh people and their
constitutional rights I mean this person
was very concerned like I said he works
for the state he drives in a vehicle
daily and he's also a police officer of
which is no secret and even with all his
training he is not allowed to carry a
firearm with him while he is employed by
the state thank you for and I will be
happy to answer any
questions thank you representative for
your testimony uh seeing No Hands
raised the representative is
excused next witness is Dr leard
cor represented new you uh
representative Burt has left the the
hearing do you see uh Dr Korn in
attendance
here we go um I was just able to unmute
you can hear me now you can hear you Dr
hi thank you uh um yes I'm testifying in
opposition to this bill um and as I've
said before I am Leonard Korn I am a a
psychiatrist in
Portsmouth uh I am also representing the
New Hampshire Medical Society and the
New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society and uh uh
um I'm testifying in opposition to this
bill I realize that there are already
preemption uh preventing school boards
from um um providing for safety relative
to guns and I don't agree with that uh
already uh um that we already have that
but I want to I want to oppose this bill
which is just expanding the
preemption it ought to be necessary for
communities as well as school boards as
well as
municipalities to vote to make their
communities safer regarding guns knives
and other things that people may carry
with them uh it is interesting to me
that again we have another piece of
legislation that would um
attempt to uh promote violence rather
than discourage
violence and I I think we need greater
safety rather than less safety in our
communities so please vote against this
Bill thank you very
much thank you Dr cor for your
testimony representative true thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh
the way I'm I'm reading the bill
basically the only change in the RSA is
it's adding
penalties for uh for
violating
uh the ordin the the state
rsas are you are you
against are you against is that what you
against you're against the the addition
of uh penalties yes I'm against uh the
addition of penalties uh for communities
uh trying to make themselves safer
rather than less
safe thank you thank you thank you
excuse me thank you Dr k for your
testimony see no further hands raised Dr
cor you excuse thank
you
[Music]
Romero can you hear me hello yes we can
hear you thank you um I will do my best
been in the two minutes I respectfully
ask you to vote against
hp37 I have to say this morning I'm
starting to feel very frustrated
everything
that I'm hearing is about the right to
bear arms as if this were the endall and
Beall of how we live in New Hampshire um
they're owning a gun is not the only way
for citizens to protect themselves
sensible gun legislations are um also
are
self-defense I'm frustrated that the gun
lobby has shown no interest um or
willingness to to sit down with those
who oppose expanding these laws and to
really uh find common ground to look at
the fact that gun violence is a Public
Health crisis in this country um it's
very frustrating to me that that all the
testimony I hear this morning is about
my rights and the danger that I might be
in uh to to exercise my rights I'm just
going to finish by saying that as a
mother a grandmother and a retired
School social worker I say categorically
the Firearms have absolutely no place in
the school Educators and parents and
school administrators have a duty of
care to Children and Youth and they
cannot do that if people other than a
uniform police officer are coming onto
the grounds with Firearms there have
been too many school shootings already
and and having someone with the firearm
as in Parkland will'll show you it's not
going to deter a shooting thank you for
letting me testify I have also sent you
written
testimony thank you Miss romiro for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the the
witness is excused
recognizes Robin
Robin scar can you hear me yes we can
okay
hi thank you Mr chairman and house um
committee members my name is Robin scar
I'm a president of London um business
owner mother and I'm also a volunteer
with Mom's demand action I'm here to
oppose
hp37 a danger Dangerous and punitive
bill that greatly weakens protections
against gun violence and weakens our
community's ability to enact and enforce
ordinances that have proven effective in
protecting its citizens as it exists as
it is exists today New Hampshire already
bars um by law from establishing and
enforcing ordinances and regulations
around firearms that they find
reasonable sorry I have a sore throat in
the protection of their citizens these
ordinances and regulations can be
tailored specifically to meet the needs
of local communities and many states to
provide life-saving tools to prevent gun
violence unfortunately our state's
preemption law already prevents this us
from doing so and now instead of rolling
back that preemption law and empowering
localities to take steps to protect our
communities the general court is pushing
HB 307 a bill that would needlessly and
dangerously expand the preemption law
law this law um would allow outof State
uh gun lobby groups to bring lawsuits
against New Hampshire cities and towns
if they win forcing courts to award
damages of at least $100,000 plus
attorneys fees the bill would also
prohibit localities from using insurance
policies to cover these I think um Tracy
brette mentioned this it's not
unreasonable that a town might want to
do everything they can to keep someone
with a loaded gun off of school grounds
high school grounds element school it's
not unreasonable that Durham would like
to take steps that they keep that they
can keep Firearms out of the hands of 18
and 19 year olds dealing with pressures
and influences that are part of a daily
college life I can't think of a worse
thing than including guns into uh into
colleges it's not unreasonable that
local law enforcement be provided the
added tools that they need to keep their
citizens safe and to those of you who
are supportive of philosophy that it's
important to give local communities more
ability to govern themselves this bill
stands firmly in opposition to that
guided principle um I mailed you guys
Test full my full testimony I tried to
make this um short and sweet I ask that
you not move forward with
hp37 thank thank thank you very much for
your
testimony thank you seeing no hand hands
raised the witnesses excuse thank you so
much can't even talk
what's the last
name
W
Lauren Lawrence a Lawrence I do not
there's only two L's that I'm seeing
let me Che Cindy
White Cindy White yes yes she's
here want me to allow a to yes all right
thank you Mr
chair yes um good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee can you
hear me yes we can thank you my name is
Cindy White I live in Hopkinton I'm an
attorney and a former senior Assistant
Attorney General in New Hampshire and I
am adamantly opposed to HB 307 this bill
is a transparent attempt to intimidate
and punish local public school officials
who take seriously their obligation to
protect students and teachers from gun
violence this bill is
unconstitutional it allows any citizen
of the state who believes himself to be
AG grieved or any entity or organization
whose membership is AG grieved which as
uh the last witness mentioned could even
be an outof State org organization to
file a lawsuit in Superior Court of the
county of the plaintiff's residence it
further provides that that citizen
entity or
organization if they Prevail in the case
would be entitled to receive damages
attorneys fees and costs the obvious
problem with this is that believing
oneself to be AG grieved which is what
the statute says does not give a person
or entity legal standing to sue in court
the dictionary defines AG grieved as
having a feeling that one has been
wronged that is very different than
having a definite and conrete personal
injury which is what is required by part
two article 74 of the state constitution
for standing to bring a lawsuit the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has made it
clear that the legislature does not have
the authority to Grant standing to those
who do not meet that constitutional
standard it's easy to see the ridiculous
consequences that could flow from
passage of this bill a person who lives
in lonia could sue the Salem School
District in the Laconia Superior your
court if the Salem School District
adopted a policy prohibiting guns in its
schools that person could bring a suit
and if he prevailed would be entitled to
a $100,000 in Damages without ever even
having been to Salem OR having been
denied entrance into a Salem School
while carrying a gun not only is it
unconstitutional this bill is bad policy
it's unduly harsh it requires courts to
order fines of $500 for an inadvertent
violation the sponsor said that it was
only intentional violations but it's not
if you read the language it's $500 for
an inadvertent violation and it also
requires require uh we do have to limit
testimony uh to 2 minutes per witness
and your time has expired so what I
would ask is if you could please
conclude your testimony with a single
sentence
Miss White you uh you've exce your the
the time has expired it's two minutes
but you need to unmute yourself the
chair will allow you to conclude your
test oh I'm sorry okay I I um I thought
I was unmuted before um okay so uh it
would be $100,000 of damage even in the
evidence of no no harm no evidence of
harm though the and holding attorneys uh
I'm sorry holding local officials liable
for their uh personally financially
liable for decisions they made in their
official capacity would have a terrible
chilling effect on people running for
office for these reasons I would ask the
committee to itl this terrible
Bill representative
Newman thank you
Mr thank you Mr chair can you hear me
yes okay and thank you for for taking my
questions um I may have missed it in 100
of emails we get have you submitted
written testimony no I haven't but I'm
going to I I have it already to submit
thank you very much I'll be looking for
that thank you Mr chairman thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for her testimony
at this time the criminal justice Public
Safety Committee will be shall be in
recess until 12:30
p.m. and for the me members here this is
this is the time for your lunch
break
right
do you actually think they're gonna do
anything too much no Republicans are
too Laura put yourself on
mute
what one we open first
Mr chairman I do see representative pus
does have her hand
up oh she is
unmuted Mr
chairman
uh may I
speak yes you can
were we supposed to have a hearing on
House Bill 334 at
11:45 that's
true but we're still on 307 I
understand stop asking 307 no we
can I I assumed we are closed on
307 tell you the the truth
representative I was having my lunch and
I don't know what
happened I didn't hear the go Clos no Mr
chairman we're in recess on
37 and we still have seven or eight
people with their hand raised to speak
all right we will continue with 307 okay
thank you thank you I have another
question before we go into
307 I believe that
334 should be in fishing game instead of
before us because we do not
regulate the
ohvs well you know this is an unusual OB
session I don't know what to tell tell
me about
it all
right yes Mr chairman thank you um I
would like to call Mr chairman if you
don't mind uh Penny Dean to speak for
two minutes on
307 any yes um ch um chair and members
of the committee thank you for having me
and I want to say first of all that I
think this bill should be retained I
strongly support the bill however it
needs to be retained and I've thought
about these terms and I do not say them
lightly this is probably the worst piece
of drafting I've ever seen in the 20
plus years I've been to the state house
it is not Crystal Clear it's not even
cloudy it's not visible from 10
Ines and I think this bill is actually
dangerous and Reckless and again I
support the concept I support RSA 5926
as strongly as I can but what this bill
does is repeal and reenact the current
RSA
15926 and it does not have a savings
clause and I believe that's huge without
a savings Clause I believe a court is
going to strike down this bill this bill
is so poorly done that you would not
even give it to a first year law student
to identify issues because it'd be like
shooting fish in a barrel and I want to
start out with some of the basic
problems with or one of the many basic
problems with the bill first of all um I
Heard the sponsor say that it does not
deal with private property well it
absolutely does it talks about private
organizations if you look at the bill
and let me count how many times I see
private organizations or private entity
we have page two line 11 page two line
28 page two line 31 33 and
36 page three lines 10 and
15 page four line one that's just one of
the many many problems the other huge
problem I see is I could cite cases
after case from the New Hampshire
Supreme Court where they say the
legislators presume to say what it means
and mean what it says and they're going
to give effect to every word and when
you talk about the legislative intent
for
example they talk about declaring all
ordinance and regulations null and void
but in other parts of the bill they talk
about measures directive rules
enactments orders are
policies it's not consistent in usage
throughout the bill when they talk about
legislative intent which is part of the
bill reenacted they talk about Firearms
ammunition components but again no
policies they use the term components
and
supplies what is the difference between
firemen components and supplies and my
point to you is that you need consistent
l language in this bill of more
important to me when they talk about the
penalties and prohibitions in what they
have enacted or suggested as
15928 they specifically don't talk about
any oh I apologize Mr chairman speaking
if you can oh I apologize yeah you had
uh two minutes and I think you exceeded
it by quite a bit oh I apologize sir I
didn't see
sum up your testimony
and yes yes sir and I apologize for over
speaking um the gist of it is I think
this bill should be retained I think
it's desperately needed I think it's an
excellent idea but I think this
bill could do much much much more harm
and put us in a worse position than we
are now if it enacted because of the
horrible horrible inconsistent Drafting
and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you questions by the
committee see none thank you very much
for your
testimony uh Mr chair there's Mike
thoron um I would like
to allow to talk
here thank you chair thank you committee
members
uh thank you citizens Mike Thornton
Milford New Hampshire as an
individual I support strongly the
concept of this uh HB
307 it does not reopen preex uh
preemption preemption
exists it does
not uh
authorize uh New Hampshire Constitution
2A it exists it merely a allows a
citizen to redress knowingly
infringing those uh already existing
rights and
rsas by uh any area in the lower
government who chooses it would create a
Minefield for a lawfully armed
citizen so what we're asking is realize
that a lawfully armed citizen desires
safety even more than any other person
that is part of the reason we are
lawfully armed to protect ourselves and
others that's it thank you very much I
will entertain
questions thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised is
EXC
this time the chair recognizes
aing
this I'm pronouncing that correctly and
I just want to remind your testimony is
limited to two
minutes
this time the chair recognizes Jr
po I want to remind the witness that you
are you are testimony is limited to 2
minutes more technical difficulties this
time the chair will recognize Alan
Rice just a reminder your testimonies Li
to two
minutes yes good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee
thank you um I had sent a written
testimony in um I represent Gun Owners
of America a National Organization with
two million members and supporters we
strongly support House Bill
307 um I wanted to take my two minutes
to point out the
inconsistencies in the testimony of some
of the opponents of House Bill
307 um they really believe that a rule
and a sign will stop a murderer criminal
or other dangerous individual from
carrying a gun into a school a town
office an arena or any place else and
prevent violence it's not going to
prevent violence what will prevent
violence is armed law-abiding people
able to fight back when we see these
violent attacks across the country they
occur in gun-free zones New Hampshire
doesn't have very many gun-free zones
and many of them are illegal
this bill would get rid of the illegal
gunfree zones because it would uh
include an enforcement mechanism to RSA
15926 which is what's currently lacking
the opponents even acknowledged that
they can't ban guns in these public
spaces but they're getting away with it
because the current law has no
enforcement mechanism and I would urge
the committee to vote House Bill 307
ought to pass I thank
you thank you Mr rice for your testimony
uh seeing No Hands raised the witness is
excused Xandra rice Hawkins you
recognized by the chair just a reminder
your testimony is limited to two
minutes thank you um as you all know I'm
the director of Ben New Hampshire
project to Grant State progress we
oppose House Bill 307 New Hampshire
already has a preemption law as been
stated it already broadly prohibits
local municipalities and school
districts from enacting Common Sense
Firearms regulations this bill takes
that a step further and intimidates
local officials from doing anything
regarding the presence of firearms in
hight trffic public spaces or learning
environments this ridiculous bill could
Target staffer administrators who for
example question someone bringing a
loaded firearm or a knife into an
element school this bill would add new
punitive measures to intimidate punish
and bankrupt local communities and
school districts those Court damages up
to
$100,000 and make the enforcement uh the
enactment enforcement of local gun laws
grounds for termination of public
employees or removal from public office
by the governor I have to point out the
incredible double standard here this
bill seeks to have the governor
unilaterally remove an elected official
from office for trying to protect their
Community from gun violence but at the
same time the New Hampshire house and
Governor Chris n refused to do anything
about state legislators and party
leaders who share racist anti-semitic
and sexist messages that encourage
violence we urge the committee to vote
this bill down and instead spend your
time on the real issues facing our state
thank
you thank you m Hawkins for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused
at this time the chair recognizes
Cordell
Johnson and just to reminder Mr uh
Johnston your testimony is limited to
two
minutes thank you Mr chairman Cordell
Johnston representing the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and we very much
oppose this bill it really is a pretty
disturbing Bill uh two points first of
all towns are already preempted from any
kind of gun regulation as several people
have stated uh the current law is very
comprehensive and and there's no need
for any new any new
legislation but uh local governing
bodies do have the authority to control
the use of town property that is a
pretty basic and obvious
proposition this bill would override
that it says there can be no regulation
of the use of firearms on Town property
not not talking here about possession
talking about the use of firearms on
Town property under this bill people
would have an absolute right for example
to set up a shooting range on a
town-owned athletic field in a town
Cemetery in a town forest or anywhere
else um it even says that a private
entity that leases town-owned property
cannot regulate the use of firearms so
if a town owns some fields that it
leases to a local farmer which is a
fairly common practice in New Hampshire
the farmer could not restrict the use
guns on that property the second Point
um I want to mention is the way this
bill treats local officials by
subjecting them to fines and damages of
up to
$100,000 plus attorney fees if they make
an innocent mistake Selectmen and City
councilors and Alderman are just average
people uh every one of them is a
volunteer trying to do something for
their town and they're not legal experts
occasionally they adopt an ordinance or
a regulation that turns out to be
invalid that's called a mistake and when
it happens it is very quickly corrected
by the town attorney or in some cases by
a court that is the enforcement
mechanism not helpful to have the state
legislature
threat Mr thank you Mr Joseph for your
testimony you have reached uh your time
has
expired
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
the witness for his
testimony you didn't let him wrap
up minute one question one comment one
sentence Mr we have to be
consistent
is
uh Cordell back up Mr
chair um we
have there's another pH number I can't
read the full number the number ends in
359 that was a previous uh caller I
can't recall who it was but they did
identify themselves when they came
off and is what the phone number is 0
that's a former
representative representative po you are
you are
recognized please be advised that your
testimony must be two
minutes hello
yes chairman abis hi representative hle
or former representative H speaking on
behalf of myself as well as the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition the bill
before you is an extension of the policy
that was passed in
2011 and signed by Governor Lynch at the
time this is an important measure we as
Citizens expect or um are elected
officials to follow the law as was noted
in the Bill's findings um we are a
nation of laws and every person is
subject to those laws including those
that are elected
officials whereas those in conquered um
expect that citizens obey every law
speeding laws um other laws it would be
a double standard to allow elected
officials not to to sorry to violate
state law and not be punished we are
asking that you extend the current law
to make sure everybody's held to the
same standard when it comes to complying
with the laws that are passed and
conquered and this bill does just that
it puts a penalty for those who
knowingly violate state law I would ask
that you would support this Bill thank
you thank you for for your testimony
seeing No Hands raised the witness is
excused
I can just speak to my two two technical
assistants there's several people
members of the public that are still in
this as a panel member just for make it
easy to follow you remove those
members
yes um Mr Singh you were recognized by
the chair to speak please please
remember that your testimony must be
limited to two minutes hi um can you
hear me yes we can hear you just fine
okay U my name is a sing I'm an ER
physician um thank you for letting me
speak
um I am in um I am in opposition to uh
house build 307 I'm going to briefly
read what I already sent in as written
testimony if you don't mind um it seems
to me that the goal of legislation is to
improve the health welfare and safety of
the constituency it covers I believe
that house bill 307 is the antithesis of
this um advocates for guns on campus
pushed the undocumented belief that
empowering armed civilians would help
them defend themselves and others from
Mortal danger there have been no
documented cases of carrier intervention
anywhere on campuses in this country
there have been no discernable deterrent
Effects by campus carriers what there
has been is an increase in
self-inflicted suicide by gun on on
campus carries schools this makes sense
the more guns and the ready availability
the higher the suicide
rate um firearms on campus negatively
impact teaching as instructors have been
compelled to change their practices to
avoid sensitive or controversial topics
so as to not inflame the sensibilities
of prone students and neurobiologists
and Educators all agree that young minds
are still developing and prone to
impulsivity when in up till the early
20s or through their
20s I would like to say do we really
want to convert our schools and colleges
and armed zones where a bad day for a
student or staff member who's carrying a
gun could really become a bad day for
others uh the majority of current campus
carry schools throughout the country
have not supported legislation that was
ultimately imposed upon them permitting
firearms on campus I've put my hands
into to the thorax of people who have
shot themselves I don't know how many of
you have done that I've also helped talk
to parents when their child was killed I
don't know how many of you have done
that it kind of bothers me that I see so
many Advocates talking about their love
of cold metal above the love of warm
blood Mr Sing I want to thank you for
your testimony uh we did your two
minutes has expired
seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
excused the chair recognizes Joseph
Mullen good afternoon Mr chairman and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Joe Mullen and I'm from Grafton
Massachusetts I'm the nor Eastern
State's assistant
manager for the Congressional
Sportsman's Foundation uh the 501c3
nonprofit I represent today I'm
addressing you to express my support for
house B 307 I will be submitting written
testimony as well so out of respect for
your time I will keep my testimony short
uh broadly speaking State preemption for
firearms ammunition and knives furthers
uh further serves to ass uh protect
law-abiding citizens from the risk of
offending uh differing rules as they
travel through varying locations uh
arguably the most important principle of
preemption uh is the equal distribution
of the law um I'm supportive of House
Bill 307 as it serves to further deter
discrepancies from locality to locality
uh ensuring that all gun and knife
owners within New Hampshire have these
equal rights uh once again I'd like to
reiterate my support for House Bill 307
and I will get my written testimony to
the committee uh following this meeting
I'd like to thank you for your
time thank you Mr Mullen for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused repres B is the 359 number did
we just call we have tried to call that
up Mr chairman and um uh nobody you know
he must had difficulties we try it again
if you'd like try one more
time if your phone number ends in 359
the chairs recognize you to
speak if you wish to speak good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Jay simpkin
resident of Nash New Hampshire I'm a
federally licensed Firearms dealer and
an international economic consultant
want to address some points that have
been made but need
rebuttal uh first there seems to be an
implicit assumption that more guns
equals more violence and More Death not
so in 1980 there were approximately 150
million firearms in the US excluding
military items at end 2018 there were
423 million Firearms US Department of
Justice Firearms Commerce in the United
States issues of 2000 and 200
19 in that time the homicide rate went
from 10.2 for 100,000 to
5.0 Source FBI uniform well crime in the
United States for each of those years so
the idea that more guns equals more
death and more violence not sell second
in New Hampshire as I pointed out on a
previous Bill the state has has been
since 2001 at least the third safest and
in 2019 the second safest state in the
Union so the idea that more guns in New
Hampshire means more violence not so
Source FBI crime in the United States
for each of those years usually table
four next the bill as drafted does have
many language defects as an attorney
point out those should be
fixed next point there is in the United
States sadly a trend towards public
officials elected and appointed bringing
into their offices their personal
agendas thus they wish to abuse their
public office to carry out things that
may be desirable or not
but I want to thank thank the member of
the public for their testimony uh you to
minut has
expired seeing no no questions the
witness is
excused recognizes Daniel
ITA thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the opportunity to
testify before you for the record I am
uh Daniel itah residing in Manchester
New Hampshire former representative I'd
like to snap you back to what the issue
truly at hand and while Firearms are the
vehicle the issue is really the
legislature enforcing the Constitution
upon the cities and
towns uh part one article 12 last
sentence nor are the inhabitants of this
state controllable by any other laws in
those to which they or their
representative have given their
consent part two article two the supreme
legislative power within this state
should be vested in the Senate and House
of Representatives it is about you
ensuring that the towns counties and
school districts do not act under the
color of law now I've recognized that
there are problems with the way that
this bill has been crafted however you
also have at hand RSA
643 colon 1 official oppression you
could link such violation to that law
and that would actually limit the
financial liability of the Bad actors uh
because it'd be limited to uh
$2,500 the penalty for a
misdemeanor um I would advise you to uh
go forward with this effort and ensure
that the cities and towns counties uh do
not violate the constitution by acting
under the color of law I'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you for your testimony seeing No
Hands raised the witnesses
exuse the chair recognizes Lauren
leage just a reminder your testimony is
limited to two
minutes good afternoon um can everyone
hear me yes we can okay my name is
Lauren paig I am the New Hampshire state
director um for the National Rifle
Association we are in strong support of
House Bill 307 it's one of our top
priorities session State Firearms
preemption was enacted by the new ham
Hampshire General Court to avoid a
confusing Patchwork of firearm laws
across the state over recent years
numerous local governments have
attempted to enact gun Control
ordinances in violation of this law the
potential for a myriad of local firearm
laws makes compliance very difficult and
near impossible for law abiding gun
owners this creates a situation where
gun owners and Sportsmen have difficulty
even knowing uh about certain laws much
less understanding where they apply
within the city limits um I would just
point out that New Hampshire has 234
established municipalities and it's
incredibly difficult to imagine a
workable system if we had 234 different
sets of firearm laws across the state
and I'm happy to take any
questions
representative B you recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh for your
testimony I know for a fact that other
states uh have these types of uh laws of
I don't know if you could point out one
or two of the states that have this and
how things haven't gone the heck and you
know how everybody survived and it's
better for the people of those States so
I think New Hampshire should have this
happy to um Indiana is one state where
we supported a preemption bill in that
state um it's just important to note
this isn't expanding preemption I mean
preemption is the state law this is
setting up an enforcement mechanism for
it so that these um violations are
addressed I'd be happy to provide a list
to the committee of the states that have
similar laws and sort of the impacts of
those laws if that's
helpful thank you Mr chairman
seeing no further hands raised the
witnesses is
excused are there any members of the
public that are in attendants that wish
to testify that haven't testified
already please raise your
hand seeing No Hands raised at this
time the chair will adjourn the public
hearing on house
307 on host Bill 307 we had 50 people
sign in in support of the bill
256 sign in against the bill uh and we
had one person who signed in as
neutral thank you representative Muse at
this time the the chair will uh open the
public hearing on House Bill
334 and just just to State uh general
public for the purposes of this bill
this public hearing a public testimony
will be limited to one minute per
witness uh with the exception of the
member introducing the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and find
committee members I am representative
John Bert and I represent represent you
want to take the witness seat oh um I I
can um it's easier probably more they
can hear me and I just won't ask
questions which I know is a rule you
know it's up to you I'm not 100% the
rule I if you just don't my the chose to
keep it all right other me when they
testified in person
the I would want representative
represent micophone with
you
yourself uh thank you Mr chairman and
fine Representatives um I am
representative John Bert
I represent gown we and Deen District
39 uh Mr chairman I'm introducing this
bill uh because it is basically it's a
real easy bill it's
housekeeping so I can't imagine you know
much opposition on this bill because
currently we have constitutional
carry now there is a fishing game
law I believe it's
25- a Col
20 that forbids anybody on a
four-wheeler or snowmobile from carrying
a loaded
pistol with constitutional
carry the New Hampshire AGS already
instructed the fishing game that if they
arrest anybody on this it's going to be
thrown out because constitutional
carryer will supersede this law so this
is basically just a clean up they want
to you know get rid of this off the
books and that's all this is it just
puts us in line for constitutional carry
which uh we have and it's current law
thank you Mr
chairman representative Tru thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative take
my question if that's the correct uh
fishing game law
25820 is that a fishing game Ru ruling
is that is that is that an RSA that's an
actual RSA that fishing game
has thank you for the
question representative walls thank you
Mr I believe it was Senate Bill 500
100 um two terms ago uh rep Senator
avard put in and it passed it is current
law that took care of the rifles and
long you know long guns in that section
um this bill this is my second time with
this bill because the Senate two terms
ago said that it took care of this
particular law so that's why they didn't
pass it through and they have since seen
oops uh that is not correct so the law
is still there Senate Bill 500 did not
remove this like it we they thought it
would yeah so that's why uh rifles and
long guns are not included in here it's
only
pistols seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the representative for his
testimony thank you Mr
chairman
representative you're not you may still
assist the committee with your technical
support yes you're not off the hook
yes at this time the
chair she recognizes uh Penny
Dean yep right
there sorry the unmute button didn't
come on the screen for me right away
I yes sir um I would just say that I'm
in strong support of passing the bill as
written it is very simple and it does
quite frankly keep a lot of um police
officers and prosecutors from wasting
their time because what happens is they
arrest someone they charge them they
determine they can't prosecute them they
made the person spend a lot of money and
go through a lot of grief and this is
going to allow what should be and what's
meant to be clear so that we don't have
state officials County officials all
wasting our time and our money and
taxpayer dollars and happy to answer any
questions and I'm sorry I'm from
conquered New Hampshire I didn't say
that thank you seeing No Hands raised I
want to thank the witness for our
testimony thank you at this time the
chair recognizes representative
Erica Le on
sorry Mr chairman um I'm not seeing that
name
Erica at this time the chair recognize
Dr Joe
Hannon good afternoon members of the
committee uh thank you for listening to
me again today um my name is Joe Hannon
vice president for Gunners of New
Hampshire we are in strong support of HB
uh like uh the sponsoring representative
said this bill is pretty much a
housekeeping bill in a sense uh we
already had uh the section changed in
law to allow permitless carry the
current uh statute section 215 a20 uh
says no person shall carry um a fire a
loaded firearm but the exception is if
there is a permit issued under RSA 159
well
159 uh section noran numeral 3
uh pretty much says that uh you know the
availability to to of a license to carry
a loaded pistol or revolver under this
section or under any other provision of
law shall not be construed to impose a
Prohibition on the unlicensed transport
or carry of a firearm in a vehicle on or
about one's person whether openly
concealed loaded or unloaded etc etc so
you know this bill is just keeping in
line with
other I want to thank Dr Hannah for his
testimony but one minut minut
limitations
expired seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused at this time the the chair is
recognizing Lauren
leage good afternoon um Lauren Lage on
behalf of the National Rifle Association
Again State direct director for New
Hampshire um in an effort to conserve
time for the committee our support for
the bill we sent in written testimony
we're strongly supportive of House Bill
334 um it is just a cleanup Bill and um
I will just kind of defer to my written
testimony to save you all from having to
repeat what's already been
said Thank You
page seeing No Hands raised the witness
is excused cheer recogniz Alan
Rice good a um good afternoon and thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
once again Allan rice a resident of
Bedford New Hampshire New Hampshire
state director of Gun Owners of America
we strongly support House Bill
334 and I want to emphasize that um this
is probably the simplest most least
controversial Bill you're going to deal
with probably maybe in the whole
two-year term uh people can carry loaded
guns concealed in public in their cars
in their pickup trucks on their boats
but if they want to carry it on their
snow machine they need a license very
inconsistent with the rest of the laws
and I would urge the committee to vote
ought to pass on House Bill 334 without
any amendments or changes and I thank
you thank you Mr rice for your your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excus at this time the chair
recognizes Michael thoron
thank you chair committee members
citizens Mike Thornton Milford
citizen uh I support this strongly
speaking for myself the laws of New
Hampshire in the United States are
complex enough without them conflicting
with
themselves please support and pass this
Bill thank
you
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
thank the witness for his
testimony are there any members of the
public who wish to testify that are in
attendance that have not testified
already seeing No Hands raised at this
time the chair
will close the public hearing on House
Bill
[Music]
represent Muse you you are being
recognized by the chair to read the
support and opposed numbers to the
public
M uh on House Bill
334 uh there were 53 people who signed
in in support and 92 who signed in in
opposition thank representative M at
this
time this time the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill
334 CH recognize
representative thank you Mr chairman uh
the motion is off to pass and I would
like to make that motion
second CH recognizes The Madam clerk I
would that that motion of au pass has
now been
seconded representative B do you wish to
speak
to
your uh thank you Mr chairman just very
briefly again this is just a
housekeeping Bill uh they thought Senate
Bill 500 was going to take care of that
uh two terms ago and it
didn't so the AG has you know said that
you know we need to uh clean up some
language here um so it's just basically
a housekeeping bill and I hope that
everybody will support it um because
it's a good
bill chairman I open this up open the
question up for discussion
representative huse you
recognize thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to make sure that we we note who
didn't testify today so there was nobody
here from game and I think in previous
hearings on similar bills we have heard
from folks in fishing game one of the
things that we didn't necessarily hear
is why we had a law like this on the
books in the first place um and my guess
is that we had a law like this on the
books in the first place because there's
a better chance on on things like
snowmobiles and ATVs of weapons being
discharged uh accidentally and
potentially not only harming the person
who's driving the ATV or the snowmobile
but potentially other people in the area
as well uh and I believe hunting from
ATVs and and snowmobiles I think was
another issue that was brought up in the
past um so I I just wanted to make sure
that everyone understands that um there
actually are some issues worth debating
here and it's not just purely a
housekeeping Bill thank
you representative G you recognize this
question to you
um you plan on Z anything else today you
think because in our conversation you
were very explicit in saying that you we
were not exec anything it's unlikely
that we're going to have time to exec
anything have a 1:30 we have a public
hearing at 1:30
that we also have to uh we we have to
adjourn today by 4M due to maintenance
so we have three more bills scheduled uh
given the length of time I I can imagine
the other house we heard today I highly
doubt that it would be appropriate to
open those executive sessions knowing we
might not be able
to representative Marson thank you Mr
chairman I only wish to comment on this
bill on the sense
that is no law that says you have to
take your gun with you on your
snowmobile machine if you feel you might
end up shooting yourself in L got at
home represent is your hand raised yes I
did I just would like to say that I will
be voting against this because this bill
belonged in fishing game because they
are the ones that control the
snowmobiles and off off rids thank you
representative W thank you Mr chairman
uh just like to make the point that um
fishing game is well aware of this bill
uh for those of you who have S served on
this committee for more than one term we
all know that if fishing game had a
position one way or the other they would
have a representative here or online and
they don't and I think that speaks
volumes and um additionally this bill is
about Firearms not ohrv so it's
absolutely in the prop committee thank
you representative Hopper thank you Mr
chairman um having served on the fishing
game committee for quite a few years I
know there's a lot of
legislation restricting firearms and
vehicles and and a lot of that stemmed
back to the early
1900s when um people would just drive
down the road in their car and shoot
deer on the side of the road road so uh
I I presume it has something to do with
that type of behavior that is long gone
I don't think this will have I think
it's a great Bill thank
you represent did shair may ask
questions so my understanding is it
would still remain illegal to ride on a
snowmobile and discharge a firearm for
hunting purp that would still remain a
crime yeah would
still illegal to be on a motorized
vehicle I think that's under federal law
that might just be duck I'm not sure but
um I I don't know of any law that allows
somebody to be on a motorized vehicle
andal Wallace you wish to add to the
discussion uh yes Mr chairman the only
uh
awful motorized vehicle you can
discharge a firearm from is is a
helicopter or an airplane uh for the
purposes of hog hunting which we don't
do too much near in the
future information the chair was not
aware see no seeing No Hands
raised the matter not be put your
question motion is O to pass the cler
will call the role if you in support of
the motion of ought to pass say yay if
you are oppos please
Sayce
chairman
yes representative B yes representative
Hopper can I say
maybe name thank
you representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative TR yes representative CRA
yes representative Marston
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Harriet GA no Representative
pakus
no Representative
oarn
no representative
no representative muse
Newman
no representative
Balden
no Representative connley no
representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman
abis chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is
1110 by vote by a vote of 11 Y and 10
Nays the motion to
pass was
passed represent you be preparing a
majority report yes Mr
chairman will there be a Minority
Report
any want it call me every time I ask
that everyone always looks in your
direction even the people on on the
computer
screen Mr chairman I do not intend to
write
a I'm sticking up for you I think I
think redistribute the we I appreciate
it somebody will let me know before the
end of the day just uh just someone who
voted in May
just please uh let the chair know
whether you be someone's minority this
no consent calendar then no consent
calendar if this time close the
executive
session on House
Bill
y
the criminal justice Public Safety
Committee will be in recess to
thank
we are
live this time the criminal justice
Public Safety Committee
the
yes I had a question of the chair will
we be having exec executive sessions
after this
bill that's a good question there are
two other bills scheduled thereafter if
there's time I will say that for the
bills this morning I would highly doubt
that we would have the executive session
on any of those
bills I believe the executive session
would be much longer and the
discussion it take take a while I I
think with the other bills scheduled
this
afternoon we might be able to exec some
of these bills depending on how the
hearings
going second question I only have one
bill
listed um in the
calendar did you say there was two
others
yes the original notice omitted two of
the bills the other two
bills
are House Bill 579 and that
is he thank you House Bill 338 is
scheduled at 3:30 we do have
a right at 4
o' so I will tell you that house bill
uh 579 the prime the sponsor bills are
not going to be able to attend so we
we're not wouldn't be executing that
give the sponsor opportunity to speak on
theill thank
you
ex get home
early get at 9:00 at night the good news
is I we have to stop before so doesn't
matter what I want to
do I don't I don't have a list for
um no I don't even have the bill I
thought I
did
represent representative
bden you are a sponsor of the up I see
representative Jackie
Sheridan
recognize
now only have two people signed up this
week can you see me okay can you see and
hear me we we can hear you and we we can
see we can see your your a
picture live
video okay I apologize
um
I'm sorry is there a way for me to add
my video or
yeses assist the witness
and activating
live I see no options Mr chairman I
think it has to be on her side which she
would say it says stop or start video if
I if I may just chime in she would just
need to be promoted to a panelist order
to start her
video
just oh there she
is all right but she's
muted let me unmute her
sorry still warning over you you're
recognized for your testimony thank you
very much Mr Sharon thank you members of
the committee um so my name is
representative Jacqueline cran I'm one
of two representatives of Hillsboro
District 42 in Manchester um and I'm
here today to give my testimony on HB
620 requiring law enforcement agencies
together and analyze certain demographic
information um at police stops and
searches so I filed this bill uh in part
in response to the Lea recommendations
that came out last year uh which
governor sununu and many members of the
state law enforcement Community have
stated that they support unequivocally
um this item was also included in the
cost black lives matter requests for
reform um so my belief is that this
topic has broad bipartisan support um so
one of the leak's action items for the
legislature was to implement some
requirements for police to collect
information about the race and gender of
any person who they were stopping or
searching regardless of the outcome of
that stop or search um So currently as
I'm sure you know uh this information is
only available for stops or searches
where further action is taken and
collecting data for all stops is
important uh because right now we just
don't have clear empirical information
on who is being policed and at what
rates um so my background I'm a
scientist um and that means I'm keenly
aware of the issue of sampling bias um
so if you're searching for your keys
under the street light that's where
you're going to find them right um so if
we're spending 90% of our time looking
for Crime among certain communities then
that's where we're going to find it uh
so it's important to know whether our
policing resources are being applied
proportionately um we also don't know
whether all demographics interactions
with the police lead to similar outcomes
at similar rates um or if there's
similar systematic differences um in
those rates uh we do know that at least
as of 2014 uh the last time I'm aware
that this was looked at Black and
Hispanic people were arrested and
incarcerated at higher rates in New
Hampshire than whites um and at more
disproportionate rates than are seen
Nationwide and other states um
particularly I think this issue is
important for accountability um the New
Hampshire Department of Safety and State
Police have an explicit impartial
policing policy um that prohibits stops
or detentions based on race Etc um but
there's no mechanism currently in place
to report on how well this policy is
being adhered to which makes it
difficult to know uh how well the the
understanding of this policy is is
implemented among law enforcement and
whether uh we need additional resources
or clarification on that um and further
I just wanted to mention so the current
bill does not require um or even request
reporting at the level of individual
officers um but my hope is that the
availability of this information
internally U might help law enforcement
supervisors um identify outliers who
might benefit from help uh there's also
some evidence that even just the simple
Act of tracking this information might
help individual officers notice um you
know if there are unconscious patterns
in their behavior sort of like if you're
tracking your internet usage you realize
how much time you're spending watching
cat videos um just collecting this
information um I believe can be a tool
to empower officers as well as for
external
accountability um just the last thing
that I wanted to say is sorry I hope I'm
not going over my five minutes um but
I'm aware that there's work being done
in the Senate on some of the Lea
recommendations um I absolutely don't
object to the contents of this bill
being rolled into something larger um I
just do want to emphasize the importance
I think of collecting and Reporting
demographic information um just so we
have a clear picture of how our our
police resources are being applied
across different communities um so thank
you for your time and I look forward to
taking your
questions representative Bert you
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative uh
for your testimony
today you spoke that uh Governor sununu
supports uh legislation like this does
he support this particular legislation
you know does he appr proven of this uh
I have not spoken with him directly um
however this language in this bill
mimics the language and the Lea
recommendation so I presume
so
representative Hopper thank you uh Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question
um one of the a key variable in whether
or not somebody does or does not
interact with law enforcement is family
structure have you uh thought of adding
that to your list of
um uh demographic
information I had not considered
that thank you
representative
Muse first of all thank you for this
legislation um the uh the work of the
leak commission was extremely important
and it's nice to see that uh that some
of it is finally making its way to us I
I do have a question about how the
information uh is actually collected so
it you know where the rubber hits the
road is when an officer actually has to
put something down on paper um today we
have a lot of people uh in New Hampshire
and everywhere else in the country who
are multi-racial so how how does it work
in the case of somebody uh
who might be like our former president
or has uh parents of uh of different
races does the officer does the officer
guess does is this information taken
from somewhere else or do they just ask
the
person so that's a really good question
and definitely um I think a sticky point
in this bill and and similar legislation
um one suggestion that I've heard is if
there's information on uh for example a
driver's license about racial
identification that could be used
currently I know we don't have that um
in New Hampshire I think
to get to the the heart of this bill I
think probably the officer's perception
is really what's most important so I
would suggest that perhaps that is what
could be used but um I did deliberately
omit that specific um from this so that
the the rul making bodies can um can get
into that nitty-gritty themselves I
assume that you know the police officers
who are out in the field U might have a
better idea of how they would like to
handle that how they would like to make
that consistent so um I sort of leave
that that level of detail to them thank
you representative testman thank you Mr
chairman thank you taking my question um
along with representative Hopper's
question about race and so on how do you
it's a sensitive issue gender is
also uh how do I determine if I'm a
policeman what gender the person is that
I'm is in front of
me uh thank you for that question I
think really similar answer um in this
case I think it is a little more clear
since that information is listed on uh
the person's ID so I would go with that
if it's available otherwise um best
determination or you could say not
determinable I don't think it needs to
be uh you know 100% perfect all the time
not requesting chromism spreads or
anything representative GFF um while
it's not up to us to make that
determination I'm just wondering what do
you think about um if the person is
willing to give their um ID or what they
are their gender or their race what do
you think about
that
oh sorry for me um I think that would be
be fine
um yeah
sorry thank
youon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking our
question if this bill were to pass
how and in what way can we be assured of
the veracity of the
report
um oh
sorry of the
report um I mean I think there's always
going to be a a level of trust as there
is in any sort of report that a police
officer prepares um I do think one
advantage of collecting this information
broadly is that you know we'd be able to
to compare it across municipalities and
things like that and see if there are
outliers so that might be a way to to
tell if um perhaps something something
looks a Miss um in a particular area um
or again for supervisors to be able to
look at that data you know just for
themselves
um but yes public trust you know La law
enforcement takes an oath to to be
truthful on there
report representative Hopper thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
taking my question the an obvious issue
with this legislation is um uh 28a who's
going to pay for
it so um partly I am I'm taking the the
governor at his word that he uh believes
every recommendation in the act should
be uh
implemented you know that cost should
not be an issue he's he's on record
saying that um I believe you know
officers collect a lot of data um a lot
of paperwork already adding these two
little items and one annual report um
hopefully is not a an enormous burden um
it seemed to me to be sensible to roll
this into normal operating costs as
opposed to you know designated a
specific Revenue stream for for a single
report and and a couple pieces of data
um but I'm certainly open to to other
suggestions if you
disagree thank
you representative
Pratt hello there uh thank you for being
here today I got a question uh won't
people feel prosecuted if they're asked
to give this kind of
information I mean a law officer that
they may not even trust in the first
place is asking them what they
are the beginning of prejudice is
putting a label on somebody
so yeah thank you for that question I I
agree that that that's for sure a
concern um so going back to to what
representative Muse had said about the
the specific mechanisms for um how the
information is collected whether we are
we're asking the person to to give the
information or um just going by the
officer's estimation or going by a
record on an ID um if that's available
for sure something to to consider in the
implementation um I didn't want to get
into to all that in the RSA but
um yeah does that answer your concern or
well thank
you g do you have a question yeah I did
um
um thank you
Mr um thank you for taking my question
on the bottom of here list the agencies
contacted were these um agencies also a
part of the leak committee do you
know um somewhere I'm sorry to
look um yes I believe all of them
were I guess I'm not 100% sure about the
the counties and the municipal
Association but I believe believe that
yes all four of those
agencies were a part of the Le act thank
you seeing no further hands raised the
chair would thank the witness for our
testimony thank you very
much Joseph
Ebert you recognize by the chair to
speak for the purpose of this public
hearing uh testimony will be limited to
two
minutes good afternoon members of the
committee it's good to be back in front
of you again today if even uh virtually
my name is Joseph berbert
EBT I'm a captain with the state police
um and I want to Echo some of the uh the
very healthy discussion that uh was just
had but I want to start by saying the uh
the colonel of the State Police as well
as the commissioner uh wholly support
the vision of the leak committee um so
having said that I I think
representative Muse's uh uh uh point is
one that's well taken and one that we
have concern over which is uh the
determination of race uh I somebody uh
brought the uh brought up the
conversation of how that would go as to
asking somebody their race um and uh in
in past hearings I know it's it's it's
been discussed that especially uh once
that individual is uh uh has been
notified of whatever offense they're
alleged to have committed could that uh
lead to that interaction being uh poor
um and I I suppose that's all in uh in
how it's presented um but more
importantly uh
uh what I'm concerned about is if we
rely on the officer's estimation uh then
the information may be inaccurate um and
and I I guess I would be as an agency we
would be looking for the most accurate
way um and I don't know what that is I I
I truly don't um but I wonder uh what
other states are doing and how they've
uh accomplished this statistical
Gathering so uh the uh the second issue
which again was also uh discussed was
the the fiscal impact um I I think more
than anything I would uh say and again
this uh is something that I know that
has been discussed in other hearings but
I would uh say it here uh from my own
experience making changes to our
existing contract for records management
even though it it really does seem like
a very small thing to make a change uh
to collect different data uh that's a
significant change to a contract that
has fiscal impacts uh and I'm concerned
about the the 60-day days from the
passage of the bill that it would take
to actually um put those changes in
place I I want to kind of conclude my
statement by saying I don't in any way
want to come across nor does the State
Police as um rebuffing this or uh trying
to make this a a difficult process when
uh or more difficult than it needs to be
I just want to make sure
that Mr E thank you for your testimony
the two minutes has expired uh however
there there is a question by member
representative bird thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you officer for
your
testimony um during the
last speaker we had one question that
came up from a representative about and
it it just made me think about this a
lot so I just want to ever since you're
out in the field what your experience
may be on
this there are some people that you know
I'm not one of them but for some reason
you know they're scared to death of the
police when they pull up behind them and
you know I guess I understand some of
that so what's going to happen if they
start profiling because that's what
almost this is doing is you know they're
profiling the individual to see what
race they are and other items that they
have to list how do you think that's
going to interact with the officer and
the person being pulled over so I I
think that um it could present a uh a
difficult interaction um you know I I
think ideally we would know uh as was
mentioned uh in the previous discussion
we would know the race of the individual
by uh the document that they present to
us and I say that I uh in an ideal sense
because I my understanding of that would
be that that's how they're declaring um
and the how to determine that the
veracity of that I guess is is a is
another dis uh discussion but ideally it
we would uh we would know the race of
the individual based on the document
that they present us and could it uh
lead to uh you know a further difficult
interaction yes I I think it could
hopefully that's something that uh could
be overcome as
well thank you thank you
Mr chairman inquire of the witness and I
want to thank you in advance for taking
my
question when it comes to Gathering the
data in I suppose
classifying uh different
races will it be consistent with
classifications for example like that
they use for the
censes um respectfully sir uh chairman I
I I don't I truly don't know uh that
that may be a way to get at that
information I think that's that's one
thing that um and maybe a creative way
to to to figure out uh how to identify
individuals um without having the uh not
confrontation but without having the
interaction that representative Bert was
referring to on the side of the road so
perhaps the census is uh a mechanism
with which to um to Garner that
information how that gets from the
Census to uh the information that that
officer would be dealing with or that
Trooper would be dealing with roadside
um that I'm I'm not particularly sure
of and just a just a follow question and
the concern that I I have is not with
with the intention of the bill I can use
myself as an example I've seen a lot in
just my short time as a member of this
body seen several bills come before this
committee and uh some bills will
classify me as one race and some will
classify myself as another race and I
notice those inconsistencies which be
very confusing for someone like myself
especially with asked what is my race so
I'm just trying to figure out if if you
to GA the the
data consistency and I was just kind of
using the census as an example that
maybe would be whatever when when they
gather information just for
classification purposes I'm just
wondering if if that's or would it be
more specific now for example Caucasian
is a classification within the Caucasian
classification is white is a
race yes um so I guess sorry that that's
not something I could uh 100% speak to
because I'm I'm not sure the categories
with which have been outlined uh to
collect uh what I can tell you though is
um your your own experience um uh is is
what I is what I worry about so I
clearly I want the information that is
provided to be accurate and I don't
think that the issue will be the
veracity of the statement of the officer
to say this is uh the race of the person
that I believe that I was looking at I I
I think the uh where the possibility for
error comes in is whether you identify
somebody and and one population that I
heard referred to previously so I will
I'll use that as an example but somebody
who um is of Dominican descent are they
being identified as being um black or
they being identified as being something
other than that and I think that that's
a really difficult distinction for
somebody to make on the side of the road
um and and again it's not this is not
push back from wanting to have what
could be a difficult conversation it's
it's just wanting to make sure that that
there isn't um error in the information
that we are providing that's going to be
so heav relied upon and should
be thank you for taking my question
representative Muse yes thank you for
taking my question I I wonder if there
isn't a way around this I'm a little bit
familiar with the with the database
projects and things of that nature and
uh adding one field sometimes is as easy
as adding adding 20 so given the fact
that virtually any of the ways that
we're talking about collecting this data
would be imperfect in some way um
whether it's identification by the
police officer whether it's an ID card
that may not have the particular
classifications that we're looking for
yet uh whether it's information from the
accused themselves that may or may not
be true that the issue is is it's hard
to get to a point where we ever really
know for sure so one of the things that
that that strikes me that we we we could
potentially do with something like this
is just add another field that indicates
how the data was collected so for
instance give the officer a chance to
say uh I got you know it came from an
identification you know check it came
from the suspect check or it came from
me and that way we would know uh we
would have the identification and we
would also have have some idea of how
the data was collected and that
additional data might actually be useful
as
well representa is there a question for
for the witness to
answer if that would address the
captain's
concerns so representative Muse thank
you so much for um uh for that and I I
do think that that is something um that
that may help to address uh the concerns
uh not necessarily of just myself but of
the the division of State Police um the
uh the the only thing I would reiterate
so I think that's a really ingenious way
to kind of um look at a couple of
different data sets um the only concern
that I would re reiterate is that I
would want uh field a to be just as
powerful as field B and my concern is
that one would take precedence over the
other um it should be uh the the method
of identification should be uh in in my
estimation should be reviewed just as
much as the identification itself so
that the two are handled hand inand and
if that were in fact the uh the way to
move forward perhaps that is and that's
far above my uh my level but perhaps
that is uh kind of an ingenious way to
try and get around what seems to be the
inherent
issue thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um earlier you made reference
to and I didn't write it all down but uh
a cost
to change the data collection contract
or something like that do you have any
idea what that cost would
be I I can't say what that cost would be
and I don't think that anybody could um
for the entire State of New Hampshire
what I can tell you is I am aware uh
that there are a number of disparate
records Management Systems throughout
the state of New Hampshire so lots of
police departments use lots of different
records Management systems and some
police dep departments have no records
Management systems and rely upon Excel
spreadsheets um and things of that
nature to keep their uh their
information and while that may seem
really outdated to us um that that is a
reality I think for some of our
communities so what what I can say is uh
there is a cost that is incurred with
that and it's it's not necessarily uh
the changing of a field uh that is uh so
difficult but it is the uh changing of
the contract that exists
uh and what I what I can also speak to
is the state of New Hampshire uh under
the division of State Police has been in
an RMS um purchasing process for for
almost two years now looking at What
fields to collect and how to collect
them uh so it's been a very extensive
process and and I would imagine by the
time we get to the end of that sir we're
going to have a pretty Ironclad uh
contract that says this is what's
expected of our provider going back to
them and making Chang uh changes to that
is like as in any contract is going to
cost is going to have a fiscal impact
and I'm worried both for the state side
but also for the local municipalities
that that impact may be overwhelming and
again I I I can't speak to what it would
be because it would differ for every
Community throughout the state um who
had a different RMS
system thank
you representative Hopper quick one uh
thank you officer for taking my
question as do you know if local law
enforcement already collects information
every time they stop anybody or would
this be an entirely new
process so I I truly can't speak to what
each department does especially at the
the local level um what I can offer you
as anecdotal and my hope is that there
will be a speaker behind me who can
offer uh much more evidence-based
testimony but what I what I can offer is
that I've listened to other hearings
where municipalities have said that
they're they're not currently collecting
this information um and to do so would
cause a change in the the process uh uh
that they statistically analyze their
information by so I again I I I may just
not be the right person to speak to the
local police departments as a member of
the State Police and I apologize for
that representative thank you Mr
chairman Mr Ebert thank you for taking
the question it was really reassuring to
hear at the beginning of your testimony
that the state police supports the leak
recommendations um one thing that we
have um we have seen is that these
recommendations typically have a
cost and that cost is often cited as a
justification not to do something so I
guess I'm wondering um do you have any
concern given your the agency support
for Le act that cost could be uh a
reason why none of this gets done none
of these recommendations take
effect so uh thank you for the question
representative and and I think um
if if my testimony has come across as uh
that a fiscal uh a fiscal note is a
reason not to do something that's not at
all what I intended uh the purpose of
bringing up the the fiscal attachment is
to try and generate a discussion as to
where that funding would come from where
it would best come from um and also to
discuss the the 60-day timeline that's
attached because I I do think regardless
of where that funding comes from that
60-day timeline is is very restrictive
um so it is not in my estimation uh as
was uh previously said that the governor
endorsed it the finance should not be uh
the reason that this does not go forward
but I do think it should be part of the
discussion especially when talking about
a
timeline seeing no further questions the
chair would thank to witness for his
testimony thank you so
much chair
recognizes Charles
Reynolds uh good afternoon can you hear
me uh chairman
yes we can hear you okay uh good
afternoon chairman abis and uh members
of the committee I'm Charles Reynolds
and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police to register our opposition to
House Bill
620 I'll be brief the value and
usefulness of accurate demographics is
not in question clearly not in question
however we find this bill presents two
major obstacles first in order for Dem
Dem graphic data to be of value it must
be accurate therefore absent the
inclusion of the requested demographic
data on an individual's driver's license
state issued or other recognized
identification the recording of such
data relies on an officer either one
asking for the de for that
information which is clearly not a
recommended practice or two recording
his or her perception of the person's
race sex or other demographic data this
clearly leaves offices open to criticism
for either not accurately recording or
worse yet manipulating the data
therefore no matter how careful an
officer may be the resulting analyses
may be subject to challenge accordingly
absent a requirement that demographic
data be included on official
documents that may be requested by an
officer we cannot support that provision
second even if the data could be
accurately recorded from the documents
described above the suggested analysis
is another matter law enforcement
agencies in New Hampshire particularly
the smaller ones which comprise a
majority of departments do not have the
an analytical capacity to do so nor are
they likely to acquire the funds to
purchase new or modify existing Data
Systems to accommodate the analysis this
legislation suggest suggests accordingly
for
practical operational and fiscal reasons
the New Hampshire Association of chiefs
of police must oppose this
legislation excuse me um Mr Reynolds we
have to liit testimony for two minutes
um do any members represent
testman thank you thank you for taking
my
question you touched on it but the the
bill requires the the police agencies to
analyze the
data being an
engineer you know I have to have some
bounds is what I have to I could I would
have to analyze you have any idea what
they're asking for
[Music]
here is he
here
believe yourself okay I'm
sorry it it it appears that they're
asking the individual agencies to do an
analytical process and then provide that
state that uh that data to uh where it
will be centralized but that would
require as far as we can see that each
agency would have to do the analysis of
of each of those categories by
demographics which uh some agencies can
do part of that uh I'm not sure that any
can do all of it but my information from
the Chiefs that that I've talked to in
preparation for this testimony is that
uh many can do a little bit of it but
there's no one we've been able to
discover can do all of the an analysis
that seems to be
required thank
you
representative
n thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question um so as I understand
it um we currently don't gather this
data just because we don't have the
resources uh
no uh uh the it's really a question of
accuracy um when you get to demographics
and I think some of the others uh
questions have been about how you gather
the
data specifically regarding a race um
clearly it it's very offensive to uh
folks for officers to ask for that
information and for them for an officer
to uh record their perception of the
race uh is fraught with danger because
uh as has been pointed out
we have so so many folks that are of of
mixed race and in the era can be high
and therefore uh the resulting analysis
can be
incorrect representative night you
recognize for a followup
question thank you chair
so you don't see a problem not being
able to tell us how many
let's say people of color you pull over
versus white people for the same
offense
oh I think I think it's pretty clear uh
from the police perspective that we have
no question whatsoever with providing
that data the question is how do we
obtain it in an accurate way uh it
should be obtained but the fact is right
now there's no way for police officers
to accurately obtain
that data as I pointed out the
officer as a practical matter is not
allowed to ask for it and secondarily uh
his or her perception may be incorrect
which in the end result uh gives you an
incorrect
conclusion so be clear there's no
objection to collecting and documenting
the data why officers why people will
stop uh what happens as a result of
those stops no question at all that
that's important information the
question is is there there's no uh
presently there's no way to accurately
obtain that
data and the suggestion of course is
that it be on the driver's license or
some identification therefore the person
being stopped has self-identified
representative
M so if if if the only way is to get
this
information uh from something like a
driver's license one of the issues I
think we all run into is our driver's
licenses are renewed every four years um
so if you if you take a look at the
Timeline you know for something like
that uh we could conceivably be in a
situation where might take as long as
four years uh before everybody uh has
these fields on their license uh meaning
that the amount of usable analyzable
data that we have may not reach a
critical mass for another four years do
the Chiefs think that that is acceptable
given the current racial climate in the
country and the state well it would be a
trade-off between either waiting to get
accurate information or rely on on
information that was highly suspect
represent you recognized for a follow
question
um I'll save it for the executive
session Mr
chair representative kman represent do
you want you have your hand
rais s you both W I was trying to figure
out how to word this as a
question
me a while to catch
on um
okay several
states do collect demographic
data
so I guess my question would because in
my my my
opinion
um would you
um representing um the chief of police
for New
Hampshire we looking at
data that other um states are using or
how they're using or how they're
processing getting that
information or I guess a better question
is did any of you do
that do we look at other states or is
was that the
question um I I can uh maybe address
that a little bit from a personal
perspective one of the projects I uh
worked on for up until a couple of years
ago for umh seven years involved exactly
this a collection of of uh stop
data and uh one of my um jobs was to
analyze stop data and
the database that we looked at were
involved about uh somewhere
between
um somewhere around 10 to
14,000 uh data sets and uh we looked at
we looked at this data uh on a monthly
basis and uh uh while it was very
valuable wasn't based upon uh any
self-identification there was there was
always an area that was suspect and
given the fact that the volume was so
high uh it didn't uh the volume was so
high with particularly with
African-Americans that uh even if it was
not entirely accurate it gave us a
pretty good picture but when you when
you get to New Hampshire the database
isn't going to be as large as that uh on
a monthly basis
or even on an annual basis so I think
it's a little more important that the
data be be as accurate as we can make it
and and you know I just want to make
sure you everyone understands that the
New Hampshire police Chiefs do not
oppose the collection of demographics
it's a question of how do we get from
the idea of collecting the demographics
to making sure they're as accurate as we
can possibly make them and if if we have
to have an interim process until we can
uh assure that that data is uh included
on driver's license or other
identification then maybe that's
something that needs to be worked out
but uh ultimately ultimately I think
everyone would like to have that data be
accurate because we're making uh
assumptions on the basis of that data
and uh those assumptions are going to uh
predict actions that may may not be
taken uh we should do that on the basis
of uh data that's as accurate as it
possibly can be so we're trying to get
to accurate
data uh in a way that's that's practical
and and I think we all need to work
together to to get
there seeing no further questions I want
to thank the witness for his
testimony the next witness is Jim
de uh thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record my name is James demur and one of
the clients I represent is the New
Hampshire Police Association um I just
wanted to make you aware just for
informational purposes that uh Senate
Bill
96 uh has had its Hearing in the Senate
that is a bill that was actually drafted
by the Attorney General's office to
conform with many of the provisions that
are in the leac report and the
demographic uh issues that you're
hearing discussed today are in that bill
and I think um if you are you know able
to hold the bill you've got and wait for
Senate Bill 96 to come over you'll see
that a lot of the issues sort of the
holes that people are raising that might
be in this bill today are addressed and
I'll give you a couple of examples so um
that particular Bill actually does have
language that modifies the driver's
license um
information in the state so that race
and ethnicity can be collected on a
driver's license which is not today uh
that's certainly going to make it much
more easier and as Chief Reynolds said
more accurate um in gathering that
information uh one of the questions that
came up is is there 28a issue uh if the
local
communities are mandated to do the
analysis of all this information that
particular bill in the Senate um
actually puts the responsibility on the
police standards and training Council to
gather the information analyze it and
actually post it on their website so
that it's available uh for the public so
that particular bill which is the actual
Lea um
legislation is making its way through
the Senate I have pretty strong
confidence that it's going to pass the
Senate so I think you're going to have a
bill coming to you that's going to
address a lot of the questions that have
been raised today and it might be best
to wait for that bill to get to
you further questions from the
[Music]
committee
wit we have uh Mr chairman I see no
hands
raised well we will conclude the
hear
Bill 6
we have um we have signin on uh host
Bill 620 there were 97 people who signed
in in support of the bill and uh 10
people who signed in in
opposition thank you
representative thank
you lawers don't take care of the
paperwork very well no they do not Mr
chairman that I think we all agree with
you in this room I
don't you can open up well we going to
open up House Bill
579 and would you like me to open that
Mr
chairman the prime sponsor is
unavailable
yes all right thank you Mr chairman uh I
am representative John Bert uh
representing gtown we in Deen District
39 uh I'm going to open up House Bill
579 require notice to the public
before immigration checkpoints are
conducted thank you Mr
chairman have a question if we have the
sponsors that are here why wouldn't we
allow them to open
up would you like me to answer that Mr
chairman yes uh the prime sponsor asked
us to or asked the
chair uh to retain the bill I believe it
was to retain it uh he's out on medical
issue or or a issue I shouldn't say
medical a issue um with a family member
a doctor's appointment or something like
that um and that he wants to testify on
this but he just couldn't today so you
know as a courtesy to the prime sponsor
which we have done many many times both
sides um you know that's why we're going
to hold
it
okay I guess the other question can I
ask another question yes you may so the
timee sponsor has a slew of sponsors
that they got and I'm just curious was
those sponsors made
aware I I do not know if they were just
curious thank
you oh
Oney I got
repr right oh I'm sorry me question one
of the reasons they may not want to uh
introduce the bill because they may want
to raise some questions afterwards they
can't do that if they introduce the bill
that's just a possibility thank you we
have uh Mr chairman um you have a hand
raised we have one oh no uh one right in
front of you if you look to your right
representative Maron representative
Maron has a
question thank you Mr
chairman with what I've heard is it a
procedure that we can use that says we
suspend this for the time being until
the prime sponsor is
available oh we have someone we have a
couple of people who want to testify who
will take that testimony
I no problem thank
you done
yeah um I apologize um I'm going to
slaughter your name so it's
um let me just bring you on and I do
apologize um is it as ma is your first
name yes can you hear me yes I apologize
I uh will butcher your name I'm terrible
with names that is okay uh it's
pronounced like the letter S and then
ma oh thank you yeah yeah so uh my name
is Asma and I am with rights and
democracy New Hampshire and I am
speaking today in strong support of HB
579 um and I have personal experience
with these checkpoints that border of
Patrol conducts in our state I have
submitted an article I shared in the
conquered monitor about my experience
with all of you via email as well um so
let's be clear that these checkpoints
are not uh nothing more basically than
racial profiling of people driving in
the state of New Hampshire pulling out
those who they judge to be from another
country or have brown or black skin I am
a very visible Muslim woman who wears
hijab um and is indeed an immigrant but
I have citizenship um the only only
reason I was able uh that I am able to
be here today is because of a flimsy
document that is the deciding factor of
whether violence would have been enacted
on me that day a violence that would
have physically removed me from my
children and family um as I drove up we
were met with uh what looked like
heavily armed military uh but they were
border patrol they stopped our car and
asked if I was a citizen I refused to
answer such an invasive question and
they pulled our car to the side and we
were detained What followed was a
barrage of questions demanding I share
my immigration status upon hearing how
well I spoke English one of the men with
a gun clearly visible to his hip told me
and my friend that he thought I'm most
likely a citizen because he didn't pick
up an accent a foreign accent I asked
him if this is how he determined who was
a citizen and who wasn't and his answer
was it's a very good
indicator while trying to find my
immigration status they threatened me
and they that that they would call the
police to make sure that I had
documentation that I just did not have
on me at the time after their
investigation they did let me go since
this is since this incident there have
been many other checkpoints in the state
of New Hampshire including right near
where I live in leban
where they boarded buses and asking
people of color for proof of their
citizenship my friend who was a black
Citizen was also flagged to be stopped
and asked for citizenship in that
checkpoint unlike me other people were
separated from their families including
a father and another brother to a
citizen that had been here for many
years doing nothing wrong and working
incredibly hard and contributing to our
community if you cannot find it in your
hearts to simp sympathize with families
with children who are no longer able to
see their family members then I urge you
to consider another impact how this is
hurting our state of New Hampshire
because many people have decided they
will no longer visit the state because
of these random checkpoints that cause
severe traffic congestion it's just the
best interest of our state and our
communities to alert the local media
when these very problematic and very
discriminatory immigration checkpoints
happen yes Ma I'm done now thank you
thank
you are there any questions by the
committee I do have a small
question the I just have one question uh
did you feel threatened by the police
asking you your
race uh you're talking about border
patrol yes thank
you thank you Mr chairman chman um thank
you for your testimony uh I too support
this
bill and I have seen a lot
of you know white people be involved in
this too so it's not just one you know
one side um that's why I support this
bill but the question I have is what did
this happen in lonia area where they've
been checking you know putting these
checkpoint Charlies up as I call them or
was it down in the Lebanon
area yeah the two incidences that I just
described the first one um happened uh
on the highway in New Hampshire um I
forgot if what highway that was I can I
mean it's in the article that I sent you
but the second one happened in Lebanon
so they happen in different
locations thank you
yes
thank thank you Mr chair can you hear
me yeah and I'm not sure whether my
video is on I can't find the button um
it is okay thank you and uh I just am I
correct in UN in my understanding that
states that are are um further away than
75 miles from a border uh don't have
this
problem yeah if you're asking me I
believe it have states have it has to be
100 miles from the border and the other
checkpoint is in Woodstock by the way
sorry the first checkpoint but they have
to be 100 miles from a border and this
was many many miles away um but still
within the 100 mile but um basically uh
most of the United States has a border
that's within the 100 mile radius
so again that means many people can get
caught up in these checkpoints the
majority of New Hampshire
basically thank you
further questions from the
committee that a
hand
David representa Green thank you Mr
chair uh my question is have you been to
any other state or country that's had
checkpoints
yes I have um I am from Libya and we
have uh checkpoints as well and I don't
consider Libya a um free country so uh
if we're trying to compare ourselves
with um what some people may call third
world countries uh
yeah thank
you any other committee members who have
a
question John we're good and then thank
you for your
testimony thank you for having
me uh Gillis is up
next yep there he is thank you how are
you can I can I be seen or heard I just
wanted to make sure you can be heard
okay um should I try to figure out how
the camera works or should I just
Soldier on Mr
chairman you have have two minutes to
testify so okay well I suppose I'll
start well Mr chairman thank you so much
for the opportunity uh to testify today
my name is Je Binet I'm the legal
director uh for the ACLU of New
Hampshire and on behalf of that
organization I'm here in support of HB
579 I did submit last night uh for the
committee's consideration some written
testimony um and I just also wanted to
uh flag that attached to my written
testimony just for just so the the
committee had it uh in its file um I
attached uh first the provisions of the
Attorney General's 2020 manual that uh
governs sobriety checkpoints just so you
can see how those work in the state of
New Hampshire and number two I also
attached um a notice uh in the form of
an email that was provided by border
patrol to the New Hampshire State Police
that was in advance of a border patrol
checkpoint that occurred during Father's
Day weekend so I just wanted to send
that to you so you can kind of see what
those types of communications just look
like in real time between uh federal
agencies and the state police and and
lastly I also included in my written
testimony um a proposed amendment um so
I obviously support using the notice
that exists for sobriety checkpoints as
a model for the notice that we think
should exist for federal immigration
checkpoints but because there aren't
clearcut rules in New Hampshire as to
how advanced in term of days that notice
should be I proposed an amendment in my
written testimony that I I think is kind
of a simple fix to this and frankly
makes the bill easier to comply with and
Implement for state agencies once they
become aware of a checkpoint so this
bill and why we support it you know it's
it's about checkpoints and the concerns
we have with them though immigration
obviously is the context in which this
has arisen and the context that this
bill deals with and the problem with
checkpoints in our view more broadly is
that the government stopping individuals
without any indication that a crime has
been committed that's the same concern
with sobriety checkpoints for that
matter uh now we obviously as a state
can't tell the government the federal
government what to do but what we can do
is require notice um by state agencies
to the public once they become aware of
that yeah you went past your time Li oh
gosh I'm so sorry well I'm happy to take
any questions as well my
apologies are there any questions by the
committee I have
one thank you Mr chairman thank you
particular taking my question
I I had the same issue with sobriety
checkpoint Point not thinking that
anybody who gets caught in one had even
noticed that there was one going to be
held I guess I'm everybody seems to be
so upset about a
notification uh you
know what kind of impact is publishing
notice going to have on on a
immigration uh checkpoint I mean are
people going to drive around it you know
I just hear the use of it yeah I thank
you for that question and and I think
it's a good one and I think why notice
is important is for the same reason it's
become important in the context of
sobriety checkpoints it's just a m it's
just something that mitigates the
intrusion and you know uh for folks who
be who are aware of it through notice it
gives them an opportunity to avoid that
intrusion which in this case is
obviously coming in the form of a
suspicionless stop and so I I really
think it's important really for the same
ways that it's become important in the
context of sobriety checkpoints it's
just a mitigating Factor because the
norm under the fourth amendment is you
know you're not allowed to uh engage in
suspicionless stops we permit them here
in this Li limited instance but to I
think mitigate that intrusion notice is
important yes thank you Mr chair
chairman and thank you for your
testimony do you know how many stops
they do a year in New Hampshire and will
this bill address the fish and game
issue that they have a fish and game
officer come so they can do a search
warrant of a car without a warrant or a
search of a car without a
warrant that that's a great question and
so uh the first answer to your question
concerns the
frequency uh with which these have
occurred there have
been I'm aware of at least 10 of these
temporary checkpoints that have occurred
in the past four or five years uh
there's also one or two that I know
occurred uh during the 2012 time frame
so you know there's been an uptick um of
these recently
um it would not address that fishing
game issue really this bill is just
about about notice um the one of the
issues that you're dealing with we've
litigated the ACLU separately which has
to do with can Federal immigration
agents use these stops to essentially
engage in drug enforcement and then hand
those individuals over the state to
state authorities for
prosecution uh for State crimes and in
in one case that we litigated a state
court judge ruled that that actually
violated the New Hampshire Constitution
because the use of dogs was
impermissible because to use dogs you
actually need Reasonable Suspicion and
obviously none none of that is occurring
here dogs are being run along these cars
without any indication of criminal
activity so the problem that you're
raising representative berd is actually
kind of being addressed or was addressed
I would argue in separate
litigation thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um do you know what the process
is when a federal
agency is planning on uh conducting a
checkpoint in New Hampshire do they
contact the State Police the local
police the County police but who gets
contacted or do they have to contact
anybody it's a great question I mean
they probably don't have to contact
anyone but they do um because uh they're
engag ing in these stops on freeways
obviously the state troopers you know
monitor freeways uh on the part of the
state and so what we've noticed through
some public records requests is that
when these checkpoints are set up it is
a very routine practice for the federal
agencies to notify the State Police in
advance and in recognition of that
practice we think it's only fair then at
that point for the state agency that
gets that notice than to just tell the
public um that it's that's occurring so
that that is why I wanted to attach to
my testimony as exhibit to what that
notice looks like that's a document we
received in response to a public records
request thank
you represent Newman you recognize for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question could you
just give a brief comparison of how DWI
sites are run and how these uh
immigration sites might be run for
instance I think in DWI they do like
every 10th car or something like that
are they similar or are they different
yeah I you know I I'm not sure how it's
done with respect to the the number of
cars that are stopped but I can tell you
U when you look at exhibit one which is
the AG's manual on sobriety checkpoints
you have to submit a plan as to how
you're going to conduct the checkpoint
and probably address that very issue
representative new that you flagged the
frequency with which with which you're
going to stop um automobiles you need to
let the Attorney General's office know
um and you also need to get I believe
court approval in advance and part of
that plan to conduct the checkpoint
includes a plan for advanced notice
which is why I think there's some appeal
here of having some advanced notice with
respect to immigration checkpoints I
mean it is a somewhat different context
here but I think that's the idea behind
trying to create similar notice here uh
than that exists in sobriety
checkpoints representative Knight thank
you chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um when you do the DWI checkpoints do
you ask for any demographic
information um great question I actually
don't know um the specific questions
that uh are asked uh I could look at the
AG memo and maybe that would provide
guidance but you're not going to get
asked for example like your citizenship
I don't think that's not gered I would
think to the sobriety analysis whereas
that is a question obviously asked as
part of these immigration
[Music]
checkpoints see seeing no hand raised I
want to thank the witness for his
testimony thank you very much members of
the
committee yeah
representative
Perez just a reminder that your
testimony is limited to two
minutes no how dids did I click on the
wrong
one no both of them are down there I
apologize Mr chairman okay can you hear
me
now yes represent yes representative
Perez okay thank you thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um as an immigrant and a personal
colored I support this bill because it
is hard for people no matter no matter
where you're from no matter yes it
happens to people with uh with a a
lighter color but it happens more for
people like
me and it's and it's difficult to to
explain how how it is to everywhere you
go if you think you're GNA get close to
the 100 miles and sometimes it's
difficult to remind yourself exactly
where you hun 100 miles are and then
carrying you US citizenship everywhere
you go because I wasn't born here yes I
am a US citizen now but I you know it's
difficult to be carrying you US
citizenship everywhere you go and if you
lose that citizenship you have to pay to
get a new one and sometime you have to
wait a year to three years to get a new
one so that's one of the reason that I'm
supporting this bill because we need to
make sure that people
realize yes um it is important to have
the checkpoints but at the same time it
is important for uh people not be
discriminated because they're colored or
because of the accident or anything like
that and then don't feel like
um scared to to go and visit these
beautiful places in new hire and be
scared that you're going to be um
stopping in one of these checkpoints and
you don't have your citizenship and you
can go to jail and sometime it takes
days or maybe couple of weeks before you
can get out of jail even though you are
US
citizen and thank you that that that was
my testimony
thank thank you representative for your
testimony and the chair just will have a
question so and I'll just preface this
by by saying my father immigrated to
this country and was uh came in American
citizen and I don't recall him ever in
his entire life since passed away but he
ever carried his any paper for with him
showing that he was United States
citizen so is that the concern that you
have that you you don't there's no no
reason for you to car I wouldn't see one
is that the concern you have with the
these
checkpoints well the the problem with
the checkpoints now is like before it it
does it didn't used to be this way that
people be so scared about being put on
yell because you you don't have you you
know your passport or you your USA
citizenship but now they it it is
difficult because a lot of police
department they take you know they now
they they uh they feel like they have
the immigration uh right and then if you
don't have a legal right they can uh
send you to the immigration department
and sometimes if you don't have any of
these documentations to prove that um
you are you a citizen even though you
are you can be put in yell and then you
have to pay a lawyer until you know all
these clears and and they they figure it
out you that in reality you are US
citizen
thank you for taking my question and uh
thank you for your testimony you're
welcome seeing no members with their
hand raised I want to thank the
representative for her
testimony chairman I recognized
Sebastian
FES can you guys hear me well yes we can
hear you uh okay thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee
uh my name is Sebastian Fuentes I'm just
a member of the community and I'm here
to express my support for this bill uh
I'm one of the few immigrants uh we went
viral with this video uh that was
recorded with our interaction with CBP
in wock in Hampshire I moved to New
Hampshire um because of the Liberties
that I promoted because it for me is
truly is a really H secluded area but
most most more even so A beautiful state
especially when you head up nor to the
White Mountains which is where I live
and work uh it's a great place to raise
my family and it's free of those dangers
of the uh the big city I live in Thorton
which is the next town right after
Woodstock of 993 which is where all
these checkpoints happen most of the
time I experienced firsthand the
treatment and professional conduct from
my custom water Patrol they detain me
three times already with no valid reason
when I'm headed to work you know my my
children are often scared for safety
because they don't know what's going to
happen even though I'm here I'm a US
citizen um I also work in the
hospitality industry and I do understand
the discomfort for many Travelers coming
to the White Mountains in many in
instances I have friends calling me or
family members calling me ahead of time
to find out if these bordered patrol
checkpoints are going to happen in the
highway mind you not because they have
any issue with their status they're all
US citizens they just don't want to deal
they just don't want the families and
children to experience the level of
harassments from law enforce law
enforcement especially in our state they
just don't want to deal with it I do
understand that CBP is following
directions I do get the pack that all
our borders need to be secure uh but the
fact that there's a lot of residents in
New Hampshire do not know that CBP has
this 100 mile Authority from any water
line that's all of New Hampshire that's
about 80% of ver off they can come and
go literally with no
repercussion uh they can harass innocent
drivers
uh there's no excuse they only ask your
ciip citizenship uh they often they
judge the drivers by the accient if
you're a foreigner you have to expect
you're going to be detained for at least
an
hour they can assume that we're risky
citizens because of our skin color and
sometimes like my friend Asma because
you're wearing a hijab you know I also
on my on my last time that I got
detained I suffer from Asma Mr fres we
do have the limit testimony to two
minutes uh her witness and the the time
limit has expired I I do have the chair
does have a question of the witness if
you don't mind let me just unmute you
before you did mention that you there
was a video that you recorded that went
viral would you be able to forward a
copy of that video to the committee uh
yes sir yes sir absolutely and I think
theu has it as well um I'll be able to
provide that to you yeah and if you go
on on the New Hampshire uh General cour
website to our committee there is an
email for the entire committee if not I
would ask if the ACLU they listening to
please forward the video as well
Absolutely I'll do
so representative Newman you have a
question yes I do uh chairman Mr
chairman thank
you
um s your experience the uh they said
You' been stopped three times in in one
of these checkpoints is it your opinion
that they were you were randomly stopped
or that there was some other reason they
might have stopped
you it can be a combination of
everything you know uh um they they they
pull me over pull me over to the side uh
they're waiting for me to check my my
status to check who I am I think to
check my license plate uh to see you
know my C registration to see who I am
and then after that they let me go uh
but yeah that's that's pretty much what
they do um I I I don't know if it's the
skin color I don't know if it's my
accent which is pretty clear uh you know
I don't know sir but it's uh I think
it's something that needs to stop and
also you know like I said uh think it
was asked to a seu member about um when
this happen it happened during holidays
in New Hampshire it happened during
Memorial Day Weekend Labor Day weekend
Fourth of July and also now the new
trend is that happens during by week in
lonia
uh they know there's a lot of bikers
coming in and out and it's going to stop
randing people and and stop them for you
know for carrying drugs with them which
I think that's not cbp's uh
Duty thank
you
represent yes uh thank you for your
testimony and thank you Mr chairman for
having me let me ask this question
uh so you said you've been through these
checkpoint Charlies three
times
uh did they tell you to pull you know
because I've seen a many videos of these
uh did they tell you to go to like
secondary or whatever they call that or
did you just stay in line and they
question you and then let you
go thank you for your question uh well
when you go when you go I leave like I
say I leave right next to the checkpoint
literally off the highway I can see I
can see everything from there so that's
my way to go to work so when I drive
there um when that happens they usually
you know you can tell they let people go
and then randomly uh Vehicles get
stopped and they ask you where your CIP
is if you say you know yes they let you
go if you said no you go to a secondary
inspection um and sometimes that's the
case and sometimes that's not the case
uh so I don't know what criteria they
use to judge you know I'm not a border
patrol agent I don't know how they're
being trained but um in some instances I
think that there's an abuse of power
there or there's a uh they don't know
who you are or sometimes like I say
racial profiling might be coming into
play I'm not I'm not sure about
that thank
you thank you Mr PES for your testimony
thank you seeing No Hands raised the
witness is excused
chairman I recognize Dr Hannon Dr Joe
Hannah Hello members of the committee uh
my name is Joe Hannon I'm speaking on
behalf of
myself um i' I'd like to just start with
saying uh I I appreciate the the chair's
uh comments about his father being a
legal US citizen and for years didn't
have to carry his papers but I'd like to
mention the fact that uh I am married to
a a permanent legal resident my wife has
been here for many many years
and still uh does not have uh US
citizenship but uh she has a permanent
resident status and she is required by
law to carry her green card at all times
under section 264e of the immigration
and nationality act and failure to have
that on oneself at any time uh can
result in a $100 fine and be put into
put in jail for up to 30 days it's
unlikely to happen but it can happen and
often does happen um and it's it's nice
to have a heads up up sometimes she does
carry her card at all times but uh you
know if you know there's a checkpoint
you're going to double check to make
sure you have it on you because you
don't want to be detained and have to be
hassled uh she's a practicing emergency
room position in this state she has
absolutely no accent whatsoever because
she watched The Brady Bunch and listen
to soap opers hours a day for years in
the early uh 80s to make sure she didn't
have an accent she actually has less of
an accent than me and I don't want to
make the mistake of saying AB boot or E
and being confused as a Canadian either
so I think having notice of these
checkpoints is is very appropriate and
absolutely necessary to prevent a lot of
confusion thank
you representative Hopper no no thanks
no thank you Dr Hannah for Testimony
I'll just thank you in advance for
taking my question if you can clarify
mentioned that if someone had a a green
card that they were required to carry
that I lought but if someone has be uh
who's immigrated this country has become
a United States citizen are you aware
are they required to carry any paperwork
or documentation with them no once once
you're a citizen you don't need to carry
anything um you know I I remember I was
actually traveling internationally once
with my uh soon to be mother-in-law and
my I now wife and my mother-in-law just
got her US citizenship uh she was heavy
heavy accent from the Middle East and
she was you know I'm an American citizen
and my wife is no accent whatsoever she
had to produce her Green Card all the
other papers and well side of Side Story
I was the one that got searched but
anyway the point is you don't have to
carry it uh but if you are a legal
resident alien like my wife and many
other people in this country uh who are
allowed to be here permanently they have
to carry this at all
times accent or
not thank you for your that's my thank
you very
much hands
raised Mr chairman I see nobody
else
seeing no members of the public with
their have all the members of the public
who wish to testify uh that are in
attendance uh already testified if not
please raise your
hand seeing No Hands raised the chair
will uh close the public hearing on
House Bill
579 question
the
chair last year I remember a bill to
eliminate DUI checklinks
did that ever get implemented we I think
we accepted but did it get through the
the mess of last Su no I am not sure of
the answer to that question I can answer
that if you don't remember
representative you're free to respond to
that thank you um I was interviewed by
NBC News because it did get out of the
house so I thought that was pretty cool
uh but it died in the center
okay how was the interview it was cool
yeah no I kept you know they wanted to
know where they wanted to interview me I
said well we can go in the house we can
go out front of the house or out by my
chickens and then she kept talking about
my chickens then she goes do you really
she's out of Boston she says do you
really have chickens I said doesn't
every Massachusetts representative have
chickens and she laughed and she went
back and they went back and filmed my
chickens because they were like oh my
God a representative with chickens I I
didn't know we weren't supposed to have
we had a speaker one time that couldn't
show up to a session because his milking
machine broke down and he had the by
hand BL
Hampshire well the last bill for the day
house build 338 it's not noticed until
3:30 so the will be in uh recess until
3:30
[Music]
good
representative
Sullivan that she recognizes you to
speak on your on your
bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee for having me um I'm here to
uh present House Bill
338 it deals with u dog theft and uh
tampering with dog collars and U
microchips this bill is identical to the
amended version of House Bill
1117 uh from uh
2020 um that bill was heard first in the
environment and agriculture committee
they're the ones that amended it it was
later um exec by the criminal justice
committee um and successfully moved on
to the Senate where it died a covid
death
um the
um uh what what this does is it
increases the penalty for studying I'm
sorry stealing or poisoning a dog to a
felony a class B felony um RSA 466 uh
colon 42 was last amended in 19
1977 before um G this was before GPS
collars or microchips
existed tampering with the dog's um
electronic collar or the unauthorized
removal of a microchip would be a
misdemeanor under this
bill this bill brings RSA 466 42 into
the 21st century and uh will um uh help
help protect uh people's on pets and um
working dogs
this is a bill that I brought um on on
behalf of a constituent Diane Richardson
of Springfield um she is the true expert
on this and with all due respect I
recommend that she U be called next um
and with that I will take
questions representative bur thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for your testimony uh I am a huge dog
lover so the bill has caught my interest
uh the issue I'm having is the class B
felony um can you explain how that
became about and do other states have
the same as it's a class B felony or is
it a lower punishment for you know what
the bill is you know the intent of the
Bill thank you the question um the um I
I'm not really aware um of how this is
handled in other states um um Mrs
Richardson might have a better idea um
but um I will say that um just the
collars alone are in some instances
worth um ,000 dollar and up um a
well-trained um uh tracking animal um
could be worth thousands of dollars um
and I'm not sure if you're suggesting
that uh it ought to be a class a felony
in some uh in instances but um values of
over $1,000 would qualify as class a um
the problem we ran into last year was
determining the um the value of a dog um
my mut from um Arizona Arkansas I'm
sorry um to me is worth over a million
dollars um but others might not share
that value um and putting placing a
value on a dog um is uh might be a
difficult thing
[Music]
so representative suvan did we lose you
oh hope not yeah well thank you for your
test your your
answer can you hear me now we can hear
you seeing seeing no additional hands
raised excuse me representa Tes
um thank you very much for letting me
ask this question
um we're most people here are talking
about you seem to be talking about the
you know dogs used for for hunting game
and so on I can tell you personal
experience that spending $3,000 on a dog
is not that hard so you
know you know do you do you have do you
have any idea what the price is of of
various pure
breads I'm I'm a rescue dog kind of
person um but I understand that they are
can get quite uh expensive um and I also
understand that U uh people with uh uh
just household pets are using these
tracking collars to make sure that if
the dog um escapes the yard they can
track the dog down so the uh this is not
exclusive to working dogs um but I agree
that um uh purebred animals can be um
very expensive and and a real Target for
for
theft Mar thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking our
questions my question is in the realm of
how easy or hard is it for the police to
catch the
perpetrator well I know in one instance
that uh Miss Richardson has heard of um
someone actually um tracked their collar
to someone's home um and uh knocked on
the door and said I believe you have my
dog and they said oh no no no no that's
not true and they said I know my collar
is inside your um your house and with
that the um the spouse let that dog out
the back door and dog came running
around the house to the uh to the owner
so um I I I can't tell you how easy it
is for police to deal with this but
there certainly are instances where
people get caught thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the representative for his
testimony thank
you the chair now recognize as
representative
comtoise thank you Mr chair and thank
you members of the committee um this
bill oh this is uh representative comto
from belnap 7 representing Barnstead I'm
also a member of the environmental and
agriculture committee uh which did a
deep dive into this bill last term um
and this bill was revised from its
original form to get to the form that it
was it's in
today um and what we have to understand
is I I'm hearing a lot of testimony
about the price of a th a purebred dog
Etc but what people don't realize is is
with these working dogs and these
hunting dogs is it's not the value
actual dollar value of the dog it's the
time
in that's put into the training which is
which is invaluable you cannot place
dollar value on that time and training
because a good hunting or tracking
dog isn't worth what you paid for it's
worth a lot more than that and as Miss
Richardson will
testify um when these collars people can
remove the collars so it' be very hard
to track the dogs but people think that
they're doing the right thing because
these dogs
are being harmed by doing their job and
what we're trying to do is put something
on the books that will say to people you
know what these dogs are healthy dogs
they're they doing their job they love
doing their job and um because dogs love
to serve their owners and love to do
what they're meant to do we have all
different breeds some of them are house
breeds and some of them are for tracking
some of them are for working um and we
have to allow the animal to do what it's
meant to do and people don't not some
people just don't understand that and
they think they want to save the dogs
and they're doing them a disservice so
they remove these collars there's been
instances where they've removed a
microchip which is very painful for the
dog um and we need to put in harsh penal
we decided that a harsher penalty needed
to be put in place to deter these acts
um and I'm available for any
questions representative true thank you
Mr chair and thank you very much for
taking my question taking my question
uh you and some other people have talk
about you know the value of the dog but
this applies to any dog correct it's not
has nothing to do with the value of the
dog or how much time in training you did
with a dog
correct correct I can I can attest you I
can tell you from personal experience
that I had a rescue dog that someone
actually stole um the dog cost me
$400 um and he was a working dog and uh
someone just didn't like the fact that
he was a working dog and I couldn't find
him for three weeks and finally I
located him and they actually ruined
that dog I had to sell them the dog
because the dog could no longer was no
longer valuable as a working dog um and
that's just a one one experience from
for me so it's not just on the value of
dogs but this does happen and I've
experienced it personally I don't know
if that answers your question but um I
hope it has thank you representative
hoer uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
represented for taking my
question um the testimony is if I
understand it that we need a class B
felony to make sure the punishment is
strong enough to deter dog theft
my question is how many people have
actually served time for stealing dogs
that you know of in other words if
somebody steals a dog and they end up
going to jail for nine months they
probably won't do it again but I don't
know that it's actually being
prosecuted uh thank you representative
for the question I cannot answer that at
this time um because I haven't really
delved into it Miss Richardson is really
the expert on on this bill and has done
a lot of research um not only in this
state but in other states and she could
probably answer all of those questions
better than I
can
C representative Rose thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious is why this
bill is only to dogs because I have
several friends that have pets that are
are not dogss that they have paid a lot
of money for and or got for free and
love them just as much and they're
they're just as valuable to that person
so would there is there a reason this is
only to dogs and not all
pets um thank you representative for the
question uh there isn't a reason it just
seems that um this H this is a a
movement across the United States
specifically to dogs dog theft is real
and it is happening in all 50 states um
so I can't say why we haven't addressed
other uh pets in there but
uh so I can't really answer that
question tell you the truth
soes Wallace uh thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my uh question
representative um seeing that the the
theft of dogs is growing and it's a real
problem Nationwide um would it also not
make sense maybe to have some penalties
on whoever might be trading or receiving
these uh stolen kidna
dogs uh thank you for the question um
yes um we did not want to make the bill
too complicated to start out with
because um we wanted to we narrowed it
down um because there's a lot of other
things involved in this because we have
to deal with law enforcement
um Animal Control Etc so we didn't want
to do too broad of a bill and wanted to
really focus on this but if that's
something um that you think should be in
there I'm not opposed to
that representative
Knight thank you chairman uh thanks for
taking my question what is the total
number currently on the theft of dogs in
New
Hampshire uh thank you for the question
I don't have that
number um so I can't answer that
question you have a followup question
yes thank you and your dog was when you
found your dog was there anything
physically wrong with your
dog um no my dog was perfectly healthy
except that he was a working dog and you
cannot confine a working dog and stop it
from doing its job and then think it's
okay for them to come back um you dogs
are trained or dogs are bred for certain
purposes and when you try and change
that and you pull them out of their
environments it's very hard to uh you
know for them to get back into
that
so represent
board thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um so if you uh
in the state of New Hampshire if a theft
is worth over
$1,500 that is classified as a class a
felony if it's between ,000 and $1,500
is a class B felony anything less than
that is a misdemeanor so if you have a
dog that is worth let's call it
$2,000 including its color
uh that could be prosecuted by a present
law as a class a felony and you would
make it a class B felony is that not
true uh thank you for the question
um before this it was classified as a
misdemeanor and we push it up to a class
B
felony and um because some people had a
problem with the class a felony and
because people are saying well how do
you put a price on a dog what is a dog
worth
um I would you know and I'm not uh a
lawyer or a judge or anything but I
would assume that you would be able to
go for further damages I mean these
callers alone are upwards of $1,500 to
$2,000 as you will hear testimony I mean
dogs have been killed because owners
couldn't have have them track they' been
run over I mean there are horrific
stories out there and um
but when we heard this in the
environments and agricultural committee
the class B felony seemed to be uh what
was um what we thought was the right
thing to do at the time
so seeing no further questions I want to
thank the representative for her
testimony thank you Mr
chair
all right Diane
Richardson can you hear
me yes can hear okay hi my name is Diane
Richardson I'm a lifetime resident of
New Hampshire and I've been involved
with pure bed dog since 1985 we have
personal dogs that work in the woods and
Fields including a shed antler dog human
tracking dog and two dogs that are
licensed with fishing game to track
wounded
game I've submitted a pretty detailed
written testimony for you and I urge you
to read it it's got a lot of information
in it from other other parts of the
state as well uh this bill was created
at my behest by the sponsors to address
a growing problem the problem is
Nationwide and not restricted to New
Hampshire nor to hunting dogs
it's a problem in all the states for all
the dogs be they working or pet dogs and
it's uh as you heard it's pet theft and
collar tampering current law does not
specifi specifically address tracking
collars tracking devices or
identification microchips only
callers this absence unfortunately has
caused law enforcement to be hesitant to
press charges for tracking collar
tampering or removal and there is zero
New Hampshire law addressing microchip
removal at all my dogs wear a GPS collar
while they work and many hunting and
working dogs also wear them additionally
many pet dogs now wear a type of GPS
collar or GPS tag and a large portion of
dogs are now
microchipped unfortunately there's a
population segment that are catching
dogs removing collars shutting tracking
collars off and even destroying tracking
collars and taking the dogs to either
save them from their misconception that
the dogs are abused or to flip the dogs
for profit
aside from the dog's value callers can
run $100 up to thousands of dollars
depending on the type of caller you have
many states do have tracking collar laws
in some States they're felonies and in
other states they're misdemeanors it
varies by State uh microchips are a form
of positive identification and tracking
collar are a way for owners to tr M
Richardson uh we do have to limit
testimony to two to two
minutes seeing no no hands raised I want
to I want to thank the uh the rich for
oh excuse me represent
Hopper thank you Mr chair a quick
question how um I'm having a little
difficulty with the penalty so what I'm
trying to find out is how many people
are arrested for stealing dogs now and
how many of them have been given jail
time of 9 months 6 months in other words
are we increasing a penal to deter
something when we're not even
imp
uh we're not even enforcing the law
now uh currently when someone is uh
arrested for stealing a dog uh typically
they because current law is that it's a
misdemeanor it is usually a uh release
on personal Bond and they come back and
they get a slap on the wrist and it's
not much of a
deterrent thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for
Testimony Stacy
obber good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you for this
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
American Kennel Club in support of House
Bill
338 and I just want to acknowledge that
the AKC is a nonprofit that's recognized
as a trusted expert in K9 Health
breeding and training and we represent
over 5,000 clubs nationally including 22
in New Hampshire which represent
thousands of dog owners and in New
Hampshire uh for instance in 2019 there
were 141 dog performance events hosted
uh with more than 23,000 dogs
participating so it's a very popular
sport in New Hampshire and just want to
acknowledge that the current New
Hampshire
law the current New Hampshire law
regarding theft of a dog um has not been
updated since
1977 I did look at the initated laws so
it being a misdemeanor has been in place
for a very long time and has not been
updated to reflect the current value of
some of these dogs that are working dogs
and purpose bread dogs uh pure breads
that are worth quite a bit of money uh
as rep qua noted uh especially given
that they may be highly trained um and
that also the electronic technology for
tracking the dogs um can be quite
expensive and likely was not available
back in
1977 um I just wanted to acknowledge
that in my written testimony that I
shared with all of you there is a link
to an AKC article from 2018 noting that
dog theft has been on the rise for
several years now and on average uh the
studies estimate that about two million
dogs are stolen each year in the United
States um I can share with you that it's
an unfortunate problem because there are
those who recognize the value of these
dogs and they're looking for a way to
make quick cash or to breed the dogs for
money so it's not specific to just
hunting dogs or working
dogs is over you have to
limit uh testimony two minutes per
witness represent T you have a question
for the witness I have a question U this
this is not only for working
dogs pets and so on is this also apply
to dogs that are purpose bread or not
purpose bread but used for service dogs
like you know for a veteran and so on
like General bulldock has one cost
$30,000 I understand yes I can share
with you I had a contact a couple of
months ago from a woman in Maine who
relies on a service dog the dog was
stolen so that it could be bred um she's
been unable to uh get the dog back
despite a court order um in Maine I also
had probably six weeks ago police
officer in Worcester Massachusetts
contact me noting that dog theft has
been an issue in that
jurisdiction um I I there was a question
earlier and I just wanted to offer that
there are two states that apparently
impose different charges and penalties
based on the monetary value of the
stolen dog so it may be that an owner
could in fact produce some evidence of
you know the value of the GPS caller or
of the dog themselves the hours of
training that's been put in uh to assist
a court with the appropriate uh charge
depending on the value of the of the
dog representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um it sounds like what I'm hearing about
the penalties and that's mainly what I
concerned about is that a class a felony
was not considered because a lot of
times they plead down or or whatever but
it seems like whether it's a class a
felony or a or B or C Class A A or B
felony or or a Class A misdemeanor that
could happen with any of them because
the minimum penalty can be be held down
and I'm just wondering if you would be
open to any reconsider a of the Class A
mdem thank
you uh this is DC oer responding if I
may Mr chair I just wanted to reflect
this bill which is a refile uh and came
out favorably from house environment and
agriculture I did monitor the house
committee on finance uh last year which
considered this bill and they raised
which is why I raised it in my testimony
whether or not a class felony was
significant after understanding the
value of some of these dogs but also
acknowledge that they were not the
committee with subject matter
jurisdiction to increase the felony to a
class A um and I think part of that as a
reflection of class A felonies if you
look in the statute um is theft of
property over a, doll and a class B
felony in New Hampshire is theft of
property over 500 but less than a
thousand if you look at the general
statutory language um so I just would
ask the committee to perhaps review that
in making your
determination thank you representative
G um you mentioned that um I guess dog
death is on the rise in the United
States um do you know or have you heard
of the people that are stealing the dogs
are they repeat
offenders I'm sorry I don't have access
to that information I think um if I were
to speculate I would say
yes because it sounds as though there is
kind of a black market uh for those
individuals who see this as an easy way
to flip dogs and to generate some quick
cash represent Gap right you recognize
for a followup question yes well I guess
for me I'm struggling with the fact that
you want to make it felony so have you
considered maybe um uh First
Defense um you know misdemeanor second
offense maybe something else u a
stronger
misdemeanor or um second offense a
felony verse a first
offense representative this is Stacy oer
with AKC
um I'm appreciative of rep Sullivan
filing the bill it's his bill and um
Diane Richardson his constituent I would
defer to them and your expertise as the
criminal justice
committee thank
you seeing no further hands raised I
want to thank the witness for her
testimony this chair chair now
recognizes Joseph
Mullen
good afternoon Mr chairman and honorable
members of the committee my name is Joe
Mullen I'm from Grafton Massachusetts
and I'm the northeastern State's
assistant manager for the Congressional
Sportsman's Foundation the 501c3
nonprofit I represent today I would like
to express my support for house Bell 338
I know that this legislation applies to
all dogs across the board but uh I will
be speaking to the significance of this
legislation to Sportsmen and women and
their hunting dogs um I will also be
submitting written testimony to the
committee capturing my
points uh Across the Nation The crucial
roles that dogs have in The Hunting
Community consists of tracking game
pointing and flushing Upland birds and
retrieving down water foul Sportsman
women have a strong Affinity to and
connection with their hunting partners
and often dedicate significant time and
money into the training and upkeep of
their dog skills new Hampshire in New
Hampshire I'm sorry dogs are a regular
part of the hunting culture and play a
vital role to to volunteer leash dog
trackers and a sportsman of field and on
the water hunting dogs serve as an
extension of the Sportsman and women
working in Tandem and as a team the
removal of a dog's collar or complete
theft of a dog is a serious outward
attack on a hunter's ability to enjoy
our nation's time on or Traditions
speaking from a personal sense I utilize
my retriever's electronic C for both
training purposes and for command
recognition in the field I've spent more
money than I'm willing to admit uh on
his preparation going into each season
uh but more importantly he he's a valued
member of my
family uh expanding the protections for
dogs and setting High thresholds of
liability presents a clear recognition
of the contributions that dogs have in
the Sporting Community once again I'd
like to reiterate my support for houseb
338 and I thank you for your time
seeing no hands rais I want to thank the
witness for his
testimony is excused are there any
members the public wish to testify that
have not
already seeing No Hands
raised this time we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill
and at this time we do have a we do have
about 15 minutes before we have to we
could we could conduct the executive
session right now on h b
338 here we do have uh some people who
signed in we had 25 people sign in in
support of House Bill 338 and we had
five sign in against
it
thank you represent Muse represent
Hopper thank you Mr you asking are you
asking a question I I make I was going
to make a point before we started voting
on
it are you making a point of order no
just a point what we are on a limited
time but I realize that I just I I I
just want to say that I will support
this if it includes the gri amendment
which makes a second offense a felony
but not the first I don't think this
comes even close to the Penalty equaling
the crime well there's going to be a
motion and we'll open up for discussion
at this time that the chair is opening
up the executive session House Bill
338 the chair recognizes representative
wels to make a motion
I
move
38 is there a second of that motion I'll
second it that motion has been seconded
by representative green represent B you
wish to speak to your
motion
well I kind what Linda has suggested is
something that I've always
felt
position but on these dogs working dogs
they are extremely expensive there's a
lot of time in in there and and I'm in a
position now I have a dog which I bought
earlier last
year very
expensive if anybody wanted to steal my
dog I'd shoot no question
about smok okay dou problem isn't that
part of your family it is part of my
family at my age that's what happens
kids
leave get
a thank you Mr
chairman on this motion I have a problem
and I hope I can express it well
here I am inclined to be a to pass but I
find that in some cases a def felony is
not enough how do we can we amend this
thing so that in in the case where this
dog is say and I got a note here
somebody said a purebred show dog or a p
breed dog can be
$2500 my point is can we make this a
graduated type thing a certain point for
a B felony and an a felony is that
something could be amended so we that's
certainly something that can be done I
think they
often this is based on testimony the
difficulty is is establishing the value
of dogs is some difficult to do
especially in a court all right listen I
don't have a problem I I had a pure
bread dog it cost $3,000 if you stole
$3,000 in cash for me it would be a
class a felon I what I understand is
that this is this is a fight to make
this a class B felony in the first place
so I'm willing to take the baby steps to
get there I would support making it a
class a felony because I think stealing
a dog is is inherently wrong in it
is listen stealing anything is wrong
stealing this my water bottle is wrong
stealing my briefcase is wrong stealing
my computer's wrong stealing someone's
house pet I find to be more disturbing
just given the known emotional
attachment people have to that property
I would I wouldn't really lose much
sleep over the loss of you the stuff I I
have with me here but it when it comes
to a house pet I find that to be
very unfortunate and I would say if this
was any other type of property I don't
know why uh house pets especially a dog
in this case is basically getting less
consideration as property because that's
what a dog is it's it's your property R
and that dog if you I understand
sometimes you can get them from rescue
shelters you didn't spend that much
money on the dog but for the you know we
for us startop distinguishing between oh
did you buy it this it's not what you
pay for it's what it's worth to you you
that's how baseball
car and to me making this a class B
felony I I would find to be very
appropriate I would support making it a
Class A I would try passing it as a
Class B first I hadn't quite finished my
statement I apologize I was out of Mr
chairman a point of
order
I represent your point of order has been
raised I'd like to raise the point of
order yes sir you've been
recognized it I I thought that I heard
the chairman say that we were going to
four o'clock I'm just wondering if
that's still in
effect well I did say that we we I've
been given the green light to go a
little longer uh there is going to be
some maintenance done that would require
the internet to be disconnected so are
you asking me is that just a problem if
we continue
this miss another point of order if if I
may I guess I'm recognized um are we
going to go through our normal procedure
of one question per person and this a
regular executive session and it will go
on like one until you reach the point
where we have to stop is that
right the question you're asking is not
a point of order you're not asking about
a ruling of the chair or a parliamentary
procedure you're asking a general
question your point of order is out of
order represent
Marson thank you Mr chair what I was
saying was the value of a dog can be
determined by many different factors I
have a daughter-in-law that's in the dog
raising and breeding and selling they
know the values of different breeds in
different dos and many other factors
come into play so I'm just saying I
would like to see an amendment that
grades the penalty if you catch the P
one of my questions if you recall had to
do with I we catching these people
because it's a move point if we don't
catch
them thank you representative
B thank you Mr chair
um I think the bill is okay except that
I think that the penalty is wrong um
based on only based on value Alone um
and I think a simple Amendment would be
to uh strike the felony
class B felony to just make it a felony
and then let the value of the theft say
whether it is a class A or
B that's that's what I have to
say representative B thank you Mr
chairman um I think uh representative B
and I are going to agree on something
today
um you know to start off with a class B
felony I'm just having a big problem
with it because I look at Chicago laws
how well they work um so I'm sure this
being a class B felony will just send
everybody that's going to steal dogs you
know oh I guess I got to get a job at
the gas
station
um you know it it I just look at it Mr
chair is it it's it's a Feelgood bill I
mean am I for punishing people that
steal dogs I would be devastated if my
dog came up this you know Annie is worth
a million dollars to me
but you know it isn't going to you know
Class B is not going to stop the
criminals just like out in
Chicago you know you look at the the
crime rate and um you know like
representative bord
said you know let the value we have
current laws he makes sense on that we
have current laws that dictate what it's
going to
be you know with the value so if it's
more than $2500 I guess it is a a Class
B or so you know I'm going to be voting
no on this thank
you representative
n
thank you chairman um thanks colleagues
I just want to say I'm inclined to agree
with this bill but also think that it
needs an amendment and I I don't
understand why we're uh limiting it only
to dogs as well as uh representative
Road stated it just seems like it should
be
more broadly to pets it's it's like kind
of
I don't know it's it's kind of biased
and then what other concern I have is
consistent lack of data on all of our
issues that are being brought forward we
need to know how many people are already
in trouble for this how many are second
offenders right now we're just taking
the words of everybody saying this is a
problem and we have you know nothing
solid
so I'm having major problems making up
decision based off the lack of
data representative true thank you Mr
chair um yeah once again uh know
representative kin Knight agree we agree
often um I've got I can appreciate the
fact that we we want to get these bills
to to the house to the floor and I just
I've got so many questions one of the
questions is why is it just dogs um uh
are the are the penalties too harsh um I
I'd have to think long and hard about
that um is uh is it needed is this bill
needed I I don't know how many dogs are
stolen in New Hampshire is it enforcable
um evidently it's not not being enforced
now uh maybe if we increase the
penalties maybe prosecutors would be
more apt to to enforce it but way too
many questions for me to uh to support
the bill wait too minute thank
you representative
Newman thank you Mr
chairman and I think that hell might
freeze over today I agree with John Bert
and representative Marston and um I am
also opposed to the class B felony thank
you
well my I'm just listening to the the
memb speak some people are opposed to
being in class B felony and some members
wanted to be sliding scale and then some
members want wanted to
include more than just dogs so although
there's some opposition to the motion as
written I don't think the opposition are
all on the same page that's just what I
GA they so and I will just say that in I
am the representative that has tried to
go read House Bill 174 so you see where
I try to make house pets on the same
playing field on equal level so I agree
with repres represented Knight's
statement I will my concern with doing
that is I don't want this bill to fail
on its merits if you want to add a cat
or
whatever so I would say but let that let
that uh be ar on its own Mar you don't
want to see if you have too
much that's just my opinion I
recognize well I was just going to say
anybody who thinks a Glass Colony is too
high Char with a Glass Colony it doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to
get that's the way it's going to go
there's all kind of that
people
de CL B is not in my estimation not too
high
a I could
goes Testament uh somebody I forget
who I think it was B representating bour
said is there a way to make it just a
felony and then
and uh you know you decide what the pet
pet or working dog was
worth take
outon I mean that that sounded to me to
be
a an excellent solution because I'm not
sure Class B is strong enough and I
don't like making it a misdemeanor
because nobody's police aren't going to
mess with
that you got to make a felony to get
their attention
so they'll have to make a decision on
what kind of what level of f it
is so I'd like to see somebody withdraw
this and we put we put a uh amendment in
and then come back to
it if if that were the case would you be
the one that actually
goes I would
yes Rober thank you Mr chair uh again
you know hell freezing over isn't
necessarily a bad thing
um the problem is we don't like again
was said we don't have enough
information like in other words an
18-year-old kid steals a dog because
he's drunk now he's convicted of a
felony can't get a freaking job he can't
own a a gun for the rest of his life
can't defend himself for the rest of his
life because he was drunk one night
versus what the real issue is which is
people who are repeat offenders who are
stealing dogs for profit so we're not
separating out the people that are
really the the target of this
legislation from the people who might
just do something stupid once so I I I
can't support it unless we we have more
information as to why aren't people
being prosecuted now that it's a
misdemeanor if nobody's being prosecuted
why is all of a sudden making it a
felony mean that they are prosecuted
there there seems like there's something
wrong with the system because somebody
who steals a dog that they spent six
months in Valley Street for it they're
probably not going to do it again it's
not like they're doing drugs and they're
in compelled to do it again it's
something they're doing for uh to make a
few bars I don't
know I I'm for itl unless it's
amended what do you I guess the question
if I may ask what would you wish to
amend the the charge too misdemeanor I I
would think the first the uh first one
would be a misdemeanor and the second
offense would start being a felony
because the first time they're
prosecuted uh for the dog they're going
to say look if you get caught
again you're going to lose a lot this is
It's it gets real serious after this so
it gives somebody
some anyway plus you're probably going
to get shot by representative Welch
anyway representative B thank you Mr
chairman
um representative Klein knight uh
mentioned several things that refreshed
my memory that I wanted to bring up and
she's exactly you know
right we heard heard some you know
testimony from experts and when they
were asked for data oh well yeah we'll
Circle back around and and get you
because we don't have the data um you
know that kind of threw me for a loop
too and I I forgot until representative
Knight mentioned that you know if you
come to a hearing you should bring the
data that's probably going to be asked
and if this is a national problem
I would think there'd be plenty of data
and nobody had any so you know again
that's another reason but you know and
and if we're going to do the amendment I
support what Gary's
representative Hopper said and why don't
we add all animals you know why do we
have to discriminate against a cute cat
or you know a Barret or any other animal
that could cost a lot of money I don't
know how much those things cost but you
know why are we discriminating against
other
animals
representative thank you Mr chair um
it's only a suggestion but I with all
these questions I would suggest that
maybe if we can take back the emotion
and maybe have a subcommittee with all
the Reps that have uh some problems with
this and come back with a uh a good
Amendment probably be in order I I I
will tell you that a subcommittee is a
tall order just at these during these
troubling times
so that's the issue I I'm listening to
them people talk about the amendment I'm
willing
to uh allow representative to withdraw
his motion I'm just but I guess my
concern is it sounds like different
people on different amendments we only
put one Amendment forward and those
amendments that they want to put in they
can't coexist some people want represent
testman wants to make it a higher
penalty representative Haw wants to make
it a lower pen the you're have competing
amendments I feel like the middle ground
of that is what we have before us which
we have this bill last year and that's
why it was the class tell it was the
competing AR that's in respect of both
represent C's ARG and repres hoer AR the
middle ground is making it a Class B and
that's what was passing this committee
last
year could you make an amendment that
said first offense
misdemeanor subsequent offenses are
felonies the amendment can say what it
wants I'm just telling you that a p
bread dog cost $3,000 why know and if
you stole 300 he stole
$2,000 you're GNA get a class get a
felony charge wife so we're making
exceptions for an animal for some reason
which is property any other property
would not how about an equal plan I'm
just surprised we want to make it such a
light P worried about
breaking I'm just
surprised first offense I think that's
what we're worried about felony for
first
offense off I love dogs for the first
offense if you stole $2,000 you're going
to get sell why would a dog all of a
sudden it's a dog it's not a person
that's why well say you stole cash even
C I mean I agree with the with that
we're just talking about dogs and
there's so many other animals out there
that people
die I agree with
that wrap it up so we're not have time
for vote
so you wish withraw your motion about
passw that
motion love guard is there a
seconden you a second
yes call the rooll just
housekeeping withraw
yes
questions
necessary with the motion being
withdrawn uh we we will
adjourn